This is Jocko podcast number 71 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
Okay.
A helmet for my pillow,
a Poncho for my bed.
My rifle rests across my chest.
The stars swing overhead into your holes and gun pits.
Kill them with rifles and knives.
Feed them with led until they are dead and widowed are their wives.
Sons of the mothers who gave you honoring gift of birth.
Strike with the knife till blood and life run out upon the earth.
Marines.
Keep faith with your glory.
Keep to you're trembling.
Whole intruder fuel of Nippon Steel.
Can't penetrate your soul.
Okay,
closing.
They charge all howling their breasts.
All targets large.
The gun must shake the bullets make a slaughter of their charge.
Okay,
red are the flashing tracers.
Yellow,
the bursting shells.
Horses.
The cry of men who die shrill are the wound.
It's yells.
Okay
God.
How the night real stricken she streaks with orange spark.
The mortars,
Lash and the canons crash have crucified the dark
Saint Michael Angel of battle.
We praise you to God on high.
The fo you gave was strong and brave and on afraid to die.
Yeah,
speak to the Lord for our comrades killed when the battle seemed lost,
they went to meet a bright defeat.
The hero's holocaust false is the vault of the victor MTR living pride for those
who fell.
There is no hell not for the brave who died.
That's
a excerpt from a poem that opens a book called Helmet for my pillow.
Then the book was written by a guy named Robert Lucky.
Okay.
Otherwise no one is lucky.
Everybody called him lucky and he was a machine gunner and then a scout with the
first marine division in World War II and he's up decent part of the HBO series,
the Pacific,
which is,
if you haven't watched that,
just buy it right now and watch it.
It's awesome and it's based on a bunch of different books and a bunch of
different events from the Pacific and a lot of them.
Eugene sledge,
that's another one with the old breed.
There's a lot that he plays a main role.
John Basilone plays,
plays a large role in that series.
And there's other,
a bunch of other books we've bought.
We've done a bunch of them on this podcast and this one is another one.
And you think to your,
and I was thinking to myself like,
well,
you know,
should I do helmet for my pillow?
I'd read it a long time ago and I thought to myself,
you know,
we've kind of covered,
the Pacific pretty well and I'm just straight up wrong.
So wrong because everyone's experience is different.
There's things that are the same.
And his viewpoint on things is,
is just a different viewpoint and equally important to understanding not only
the war,
not only what they experienced in war,
but also a whole nother side of human nature that we need to learn about.
And
yeah,
there's,
there are a lot to go over.
So a little,
there's a little introduction here and just to give you a little background on,
on Lucky,
lucky he enlisted on January 5th,
1942 he tried to join up the day after the attack on Pearl Harbor,
but a surgically correctable condition.
Disqualified him.
Okay.
Now he was back and acceptable.
Just that tells us a lot.
He was a civilian,
not a professional fighting man,
but he became a warrior.
Okay.
The author was one of those young men,
many not yet 20 who were gentle human beings that were transformed by training
hardship and the war into fighting marines.
These were the boys who became men that stood against and then beat back two of
the world's most vicious fighting machines.
They left behind them a heritage of decency.
Okay.
That hopefully will live
forever.
Then that's from the introduction and,
okay,
so again,
after World War,
after Pearl Harbor,
there was so many,
you've seen pictures using seen pictures of guys wrapped around the block
waiting to go to the recruiting office and he goes,
the recruiting office,
he'd can't go in at first.
Eventually it gets in,
it takes them a month to get in and then he's off to boot camp and we've seen
all kinds of representations in books and movies of Marine Corps bootcamp and in
bootcamp of jet in general.
But I just had to hit on this one a little bit because it's just another
perspective that shows you,
shows you his son,
his view of it and gave me a,
not even a bedroom understanding a clearer understanding of what,
what people are going through when they're going through boot camp.
And I remember actually I remember this about bootcamp.
I they,
they wrote,
we had to write something when I was going through bootcamp,
and I don't know if I've talked about this before,
but we're going through bootcamp.
They said,
hey,
write down,
you know,
the top three things you're learning,
right?
You had to,
we all had to,
okay,
this is Navy boot camp and I wrote down something along the lines of,
I wrote something along the lines of the brainwashing seems very effective.
Right?
I'll hold you.
I was 1818 or nine I think I just turned 19 and that's cause I was a rebellious
kid.
Right.
And so I'm thinking they're brainwashing us and I wasn't against it.
I,
it was kind of one of those statements where I was saying I was kind of being
sarcastic,
but it's also kind of being true to form.
We call it cracking but FAC yet.
Okay,
we'll roll with that.
So that's what I was doing.
And,
and I remember they didn't say anything about anything anyone had written about
what we were learning or whatever they called that one out.
The,
the,
the chiefs that were running my bootcamp company,
they will,
you know,
say,
and if you think you're getting brainwashed,
do you know what this is,
what's going to save you?
And he went on this big thing to counter my,
my assessment.
So there's a little bit of that here.
In what,
what,
what lucky saying,
he says the same kind of thing and he gets the same kind of,
he gets to the same place,
but he,
we go going to the book,
they're at boot camp,
Marine Corps bootcamp in doc and here we go.
Sergeant bellow marched us to the quartermaster's.
It was there.
We stripped off all vestiges of personality.
It is the quarter.
So if you,
if you don't know,
a quarter master in the military is someone that basically run supply.
They'd give you gear.
That's what they are.
So it is the quarter masters who make soldiers,
sailors,
and marines in their presence.
One strips down with each divestment,
a trait is lost.
The discard of a garment marks the quiet death of an idiosyncrasy
I take off my socks.
Gone is a propensity for stripes or clocks or checks or even solids.
Ended is a tendency to combine purple socks with a brown tie.
My socks hence forth will be Tan.
They will neither be soiled nor rolled,
nor [inaudible] nor restrain nor holy.
They will be Tam.
The only other thing they may be is clean,
so it is with it all until one stands naked.
Struggling with an embarrassment that is entirely lost on the laconic shades who
work in the quarter.
Master sheds thus naked,
thus quivering on man is defenseless before the quartermaster character clings
to close that have gone into the discard as skin and hair stick to adhesive
tape.
It is torn from you.
Then the quartermasters shade swarm over you with measuring tape.
A cascade of close falls upon you,
washing you clean of personality.
When you have emerged from this,
you are,
but a number three five one tree niner,
one United States Marine Corps,
20 minutes before there had stood in your place,
a human being surrounded by some 60 other human beings.
But now there stood one number among 60 others,
the sum of all to be a training platoon.
But the parts have no meaning except in the context of the whole.
So there's a little psychological reason why they do that,
how they do it,
and you can see it works.
You know all those little things that you have,
all the little things that make you,
you were going to take them away.
That's what we're going to do.
And there's so,
there's this weird thing because when I went through bootcamp,
I wanted that take it away from me,
and I've said this before on the podcast,
you,
it's a blank slate.
When you get,
when you go into bootcamp,
they shave your head,
they take your clothes,
they take all that personal stuff.
And you get a blank slate.
They tell you like,
this is all you need to do to succeed here.
All that stuff you've done in the past,
your knucklehead,
we don't care.
Here's what you gotta do now.
And,
and it's awesome.
And for a lot of people,
myself included,
you're now,
you're becoming part of something that's bigger than you.
That's a good feeling.
You know,
it's a good feeling.
I liked it.
I'd go so far as to say I loved it.
And they do the same thing.
By the way.
They do the same thing to you.
Like when you get to your seal training class,
do your buds class,
you get your head shaved again,
you get another set of uniforms,
you're all gonna dress the same.
You're all going to look the same.
I think that head shaving thing would really do it for a lot of people.
For sure.
Just cause that's some people's part,
whole personality.
You know their hair.
Dang.
They liked that hair.
Now,
of course,
fast forwarding a little bit,
but I found this interesting back to the book in six weeks of trading,
there seemed not to exist.
A single pattern apart from meals all seemed chaos.
Marching,
drilling and manual of arms.
Listening to lectures on military courtesy and saluting.
The right hand will strike the head at 45 degree angle midway from the right
eye,
listening to lectures on marine jargon from now on,
everything floor,
street,
ground,
everything is the deck.
Cleaning and polishing ones rifle until it's showing like an ornament.
Shaving daily,
whether Harry or beardless.
It was all a jumble.
What are we going to do?
Salute the jabs to death.
No,
we're going to blind them with spit and Polish.
Yeah,
or Barbara,
the bastards.
All the logic seem to be on our side.
The Marine Corps seemed a madness,
so they're thinking,
what are we getting out of this?
You want us to pause?
How would you teach us how to shoot the rifle?
Yeah.
Continuing on.
It was a madness,
but it was disciplined
apart from us.
Recruits,
no one in Paris island seem to care for anything but discipline.
There was absolutely no talk of war.
We heard no fiery lectures about killing Japs such as we were to hear later on
in new river,
which is a place where they go to train everything but discipline,
marine core discipline was steadfastly mocked and ridiculed,
be it holiness or high finance.
These drill instructors were dedicated Martin Nets like the sensualists who
feels that if a thing cannot be eaten or drunk or taking a bed,
a did does not exist.
So were these Martin Nets in their outlook?
All was discipline.
There you go.
I actually,
that word struck me Martin Nets.
So I did a little,
you know,
I looked it up and the etymology of it is there was a French general that
created a certain tie type of drill,
close order drill procedures,
and his name was General Jeanne Martin Net Joan Martin net.
So that's where he,
that's where that word comes from.
And it means that you're a strict disciplinarian.
Wouldn't it be Martin a Martini?
I guess so for those that speak French,
French Canadian background
did not know her story.
Oh,
that's right.
Cause you were friends with jetty.
Jody Mitic,
you,
you and him bonded.
We bonded over your Canadian roots.
Nice.
Another great example or a great paragraph about what this feels like back to
the book.
It is a process of surrender.
At every turn,
at every hour it seemed a habit or a preference had to be given up and
adjustment had to be made.
Even in the mess hall,
we learned that nothing mattered so little as a man's own likes or dislikes and
I think that's what is that?
That's what's so cool about,
that's what I loved,
right when he joined the military all,
it's all stripped away.
All these little comforts that you have,
they strip them away and you're left with the raw self,
right?
The raw self.
That's what you're left with you and you start putting everything else above
yourself.
It's a very humbling process.
Okay.
Back to the book.
Worst in all this process of surrender was the ruthless refusal to permit a man.
The slightest privacy.
Everything was done in the open,
rising,
waking,
writing letters,
receiving mails,
receiving mail,
making beds,
washing,
shaving,
combing one's hair,
emptying one's bowels,
all was done in public and shape to this style and structure of the sergeant.
So that that one right there going to the bathroom and you get to like in Navy
boot camp you,
the first time you go in the bathroom there's just toilets.
There's no doors,
there's no walls.
Just dissed 30 toilets in a row.
He prison style and you're actually prisons have,
you're only there with your little roommate.
And I even present.
So thank you.
Sit down.
And by the way,
you can't say I'm going to wait until no one else is in there because they give
you,
you know,
you have to go from this to this,
to this and then,
okay we're back in the barracks.
You can go to the bathroom now.
So there you go.
You're going to sit down 18 inches from some other dude that's,
that's going to the bathroom,
that's emptying his bowels and there is no privacy and those,
I mean you may have never taken a crap in front of another human being.
Most people haven't.
Why would you,
so you have this,
you have this little sink sanctuary,
right?
Where are you going to get private gone?
Yeah,
it's gone.
All exposed.
Stripped away.
Yeah.
It's kind of a football is by the way thing is football and that's kind of like,
it's cool to do that.
You know,
like the coaches don't make you do that.
It's just like if you're shy,
you know,
or that kind of thing.
Like some guys they didn't have stalls.
They did,
but yeah,
they did.
They did.
But the point is like it was kind of like the cool culture so guys wouldn't
close the stall.
If there was a shy guy who didn't want a shower,
he'd go to his room and
he was like,
the more open and like whatever you were the cooler.
It kind of was.
But that's what it did.
Just the cohesiveness.
Yeah.
Well if you came in shy,
it's like you'd have that feeling,
you know?
Yeah,
but man,
I day it's true.
I actually remember that because I had never,
I was whatever.
I was
19 years old and sitting down next to a dude for the first time taking a crap.
I'd never done that before.
Why would you do that?
Yeah,
no.
You have your own little private world.
Do you have your own private space?
This is my little time.
As you know,
she's not not your
back to the book.
If you are undone in Parris Island,
which is where Marine Corps bootcamp is or where that one of them or there's
also one here in San Diego,
if you are undone in Parris Island,
taken apart in those first few weeks is that the rifle range that they start to
put you together again,
so that's,
and he goes into some pretty good,
he talks about now the rebuilding and finally in again,
it's great details,
great information,
very cool.
Read,
very cool perspective.
That's why you get the book and read it back to the book.
In five weeks,
they had made us over another week of training remained,
but the desired change already had taken place.
Most important in this transformation was not the hardening of my flesh or the
sharpening of my eyes,
but the new attitude of mind.
I was a marine.
Now that's the big transformation.
And now like I said,
they go,
they go to start their advanced training.
So in bootcamp you don't,
you're not learning,
you're learning some technical stuff,
but you're basically just learning a new attitude,
right?
You're learning to be a marine.
And then they go from there.
They go to a place called new river where they're going to do some more training
and they're going to start learning to be actual fighting marines.
So here we go,
back to the book and talking about New River here,
the only talent was that of the foot soldier,
the only tool,
the handgun here,
the cultivated,
the oblique and the delicate soon perished like Gardenias and desert.
So we're starting to get into some hard living and they form up into companies.
And he ends up in an h company,
second battalion,
First Marine regimen,
and they get some other veterans that come to start,
help them prepare for combat.
And here's what he says about that.
The first,
and this is the first marine regimen,
the first also received a vital leavening of veteran NCOC.
That's noncommissioned officers.
So these are like the mid level enlisted guys that run the show.
They would teach us,
they would train us,
they would turn us into fighting troops from them.
We would learn our weapons from them.
We would take our character and temper.
They were the old breed and we were the new,
the volunteer youths who had come from the comfort of home to the hardship of
war
for the next three
years.
All of these would be my comrades,
the men of the First Marine Division.
Yeah.
And that's true.
They,
you know,
they always try and take veterans.
I shouldn't say always,
because actually in d day they wanted a bunch of new guys.
They wanted people that hadn't been in combat before.
But you know,
in the seal teams we do that.
Well,
I got back from Ramadi with my task unit.
They took my task in it,
we didn't and they split them up,
all put them in all different tasks,
units.
So we had all these guys with all the spirits go into these other tasks in.
It's,
this is pretty normal and that's where the true learning comes from,
right?
You're going to get that,
that face to face that that hands on and that true connection to what's going on
overseas.
And here's some of the things that they did back to the book.
Drew Gun drill and nomenclature.
No your weapon.
Know it intimately.
Know it with almost the insight of its inventor.
Be able to take it apart blindfolded or in the dark to put it together.
Be able to recite mechanically a detailed description of the guns operation.
No,
the part played by every member of the squad,
from gunner down to the unfortunates who carried water,
the water can or the machine gun boxes as well as their own rifles.
Okay,
so you're going to learn this weapon like better than better than the inventors.
What they're saying.
That's how well you need to know.
And you know what?
I believe that that inventor doesn't do what these guys do with that machine
gun.
I'll tell you if you,
if you like the guys that I,
the pig gunners,
we call them guys that carried a mark 48 which is our big heavy weapon guys that
carry that when you'd watch them,
it's beautiful.
It looks the more it's beautiful,
the how quick and how fast and how they combat load that thing and hit the
ground and clear reloads.
It was like magic magic.
Love that.
Now there's not just learning about weapons,
right?
There's other things you gotta do.
You gotta get.
You still got to continue to live a hard life.
You still got to get mentally and physically conditioned for combat and what
better way to do that?
Then some road marches,
some road marches,
which we've talked about many times here.
Back to the book.
A whole battalion was on the march and my poor squad was tucked away somewhere
at the center or center rear clouds of red dust settled upon us.
My helmet,
Bang irritably against the machine gun that was boring into my shoulder or else
it was bumped forward.
Mattingly over my eyes by the movement of my pack,
mile or so out.
I dared not drink any more from my canteen.
I had no idea how far we had to go.
My dungarees,
we're saturated with sweat.
They're light green,
dark into by perspiration.
Dirt had been joking and even some singing the first mile out.
Now the only the bird saying,
but from us there was just the thud of feet,
the clank of canteens,
the creak of leather rifle slings,
the occasional horse cracking of voice raised and breath wasted in a curse.
Every hour we got a 10 minute break.
Then came the command off and on.
It means off your behind and on your feet,
cursing,
hating both command and command.
In straining,
we rose to our feet and began again.
The Dole plotting rhythm of the march
ye old Roadmarch
that's and so they're doing this type of hard training and they're going,
they're doing maneuvers,
they're preparing,
they're doing mock beach landings.
They're doing all those things and they're also getting some occasional liberty.
Do you guys know,
what do you want to liberty as as a civilian?
See,
it's an word that I throw out there.
Sometimes it means time off.
Liberty means time off and I don't,
it's,
it's from the navy,
but the Marine Corps uses as well.
It means time off.
And so these guys,
even though they're working hard,
when boot camp,
you don't get any liberty.
No,
you just stay in bootcamp for 13 weeks.
You don't get any liberty in.
Once you're,
you know,
a fleet marine or you're in the regular navy,
you get liberty so you can go do,
you know,
go out and do some stuff.
And so these guys are going out and doing stuff.
And what do you think they're doing?
18 years old,
getting ready to go to war.
They're going to go out and get after it in a,
in the classic,
in the classic 18 year old sense of the word.
Actually.
That's when I got in that context is how I got turned onto the expression.
Get after it.
Oh from the context of of going out and partying.
Yes,
exactly.
And I don't know,
partying is what we're talking about.
That's a,
that's a term that it sounds pretty lame,
but that's what we're talking about.
I think everybody understands that term.
Drinking,
chasing girls,
partying.
That's,
that's what we're talking about.
I guess it's a commonly used term because you hear people say like,
I remember seeing an article about some school,
some college being the number three ranked party school.
So party implies party doesn't imply birthday cake.
Hey,
party party party implies drinking.
Getting crazy.
Yeah.
Which is different,
getting crazy different from getting nuts right now.
Getting nuts is fighting for you.
You're getting nuts.
Is Fighting Fisher in polite?
Yes.
Yes,
yes.
For sure.
All right,
so we're just talking about getting crazy and partying and that's what these
guys were doing getting after.
Yeah,
so here we go.
Back to the book.
We were impatient.
We were wound up.
We could know more relaxed than we could think.
In those days.
There was not an introspective person among us.
We seldom spoke of of the war,
except it might relate to
ourselves and in an abstract way,
the ethics of Hitler,
the extermination of the Jews,
the yellow peril.
These were matters for the gentleman of the editorial pages to discuss.
We lived for thrills,
not the thrills of the battlefield,
but if the speeding auto,
the dimly lighted cafe,
the drink racing,
the blood,
the texture of a cheek,
the sheen of a silken calf,
nothing was permitted to last.
All had to be fluid.
We wanted not actuality but possibility.
Okay.
That's pretty interesting statement.
Yeah.
We all had to be food we wanted,
not actually,
they don't actually want that.
They wanted to chase that.
Right,
right.
The chief,
we could not be still always movement.
Everything changing.
We were like shadows fleeing ever fleeing condemned men.
Souls in hell.
Yeah.
Soon the spate of 62 our liberties was ended mid May of 1942 saw me go home for
the last time.
My family would not set eyes on me again for nearly three years.
Okay.
And again,
obviously there's some very important experiences in that section.
Okay.
That's why you read the book.
Great.
It's great to hear his perspective.
You're gonna see,
uh,
Robert Lucky.
He's a very,
he's a very intelligent and he became a writer.
I mean he became a writer.
He,
this isn't the only book I think he wrote 40 plus books in his life.
He worked for big newspapers and he's a,
he's a writer,
so he's a very smart guy.
And,
and he talks about that and we'll get to that point in here,
but hit,
that's why his perspective is so interesting.
And he brings a lot of that in this book.
But eventually,
obviously they finish their training no more partying and now it's time to fight
back to the book.
Fires flickered on the shores of Guadalcanal island when we came on the deck.
Yeah,
they were not great flaming leaping fires and we were disappointed.
We had expected to see the world a light.
When we emerged from the hatches,
the bombardment had seemed fierce.
Our,
our odd armada for such,
we judged it to be,
seemed capable of blasting Guadalcanal into production.
But in the dirty don't of August 7th,
1942 there were only a few fires flickering like the city dumps to light our
path to history.
Okay.
We were apprehensive,
not frightened.
So in case you haven't gathered,
these guys are about to the landing at Guadalcanal
and they get into the,
the little Higgins boats,
the little landing craft,
and here we go.
The assault began.
Now I was praying again.
I had prayed much the night before,
carefully,
deliberately in,
in,
in betraying God and the Virgin to care for my family and friends.
Should I fall in the vanity of youth?
I was positive.
I would die in the same vanity.
I was turning my affairs over to the Almighty.
Okay.
And I think what he means by vanity that he was sure he would die.
You'd Think,
oh,
somebody that's vein will be like,
Hey,
I can't be killed.
But I think what he means by that is the vanity.
That there's some determined outcome that,
that you can control or that there's that it's that there's some way it's going
to go right,
like he's going to die.
No,
you don't even know that.
Right,
right.
It's that he knows,
you know.
I know.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
I know what's going to happen.
I know I'm going to die.
That's vanity in its own right.
That's what he's saying.
So they hit the landing back to the book,
but there was no fight.
The Japanese had run from somewhere came the command move out.
We formed staggered squads and slogged off.
We left our innocence on Red Beach.
It would never be the same.
Okay.
They spend a night there,
there,
there now patrolling in and in the night there there Ian security positions and
they hear a little gunfire and we'll go to the book.
At dawn,
we learned the import of the gunfire.
Uh,
medical corpsman had been killed.
He had been shot by his own men when the century had challenged him.
As you returned from relieving himself,
he had boggled over the password.
Lilliputian
and so met death.
It turned a d at The mercy of a liquid consonant.
Now,
little heads up Lilliputian is not a good challenge and reply password for
everyone.
You don't want me want me to come up with something that's not totally obvious,
but don't make a guy that's scared out in the middle of the jungle.
Remember the word Lilliputian.
Okay.
And,
and you know we talk about blue on blue.
There you go.
Like their first casualty is blue on blue.
Their first casualty is blue on blue.
Their first casualty is that got uh,
uh,
medical corpsman being killed by centuries.
That's a nightmare.
Hmm.
And
I wasn't going to read this,
but I'm going to,
I peered at the captain.
Anxiety was on his face as though carve there by the night's events.
It startled me.
Here was no warrior,
no veteran of a hundred battles.
He was only a civilian like myself.
He was a man,
hardly more confident than the trigger.
Happy Century who had killed the corpsman.
He was much older than I,
but the responsibility of his charge,
the unknown face of war had frightened him pass trusting the evidence of his
senses.
So imagine you're going into combat,
you're in charge,
you're civilian,
but now you're in charge and you're going out on your first combat patrol.
You lay up and your first thing you do is you kill when you're on you.
One of your own guys kills one of your other guys.
Okay.
It's a nightmare.
And he can see it on his face.
Hmm.
They spend the rest of the day out there.
Still no heavy enemy contact.
Back to the book.
That day was a dull last witness to the cycle.
The son of which I have neither memory,
no regret.
The night I shall never forget.
I awoke in the middle of it to see the sky on fire.
So it seemed,
it was like the red mist of my childhood dream when I imagined judgment to have
calm while I played baseball on the castle grounds at home,
we were bathed in red light as though fixed in the eye of Satan.
Imagine a myriad of red traffic lights glowing in the rain and you will have a
replica of the world in which I awoke.
The lights were the flares of the enemy.
They hung above the jungle roof swing gently on their parachutes,
casting their red glow about motors.
Throbbed above.
They were those of Japanese sea planes.
We learned later.
We thought they were hunting us,
but they were actually the eyes of a mighty enemy.
Naval Armada that's swept into c Clark channel.
Soon we heard the sound of cannons and they island trembled beneath us.
There came flashes of light white and red and great rocking explosions.
The Japs were hammering out one of their greatest naval victories.
It was the battle of salvo island.
What we learned to call more accurately the battle of four sitting ducks.
They were sinking.
Three American cruisers,
the Quincy vinsons and a Storia and one Australian cruiser,
the Canberra,
as well as damaging one other American cruiser and a US destroyer.
Okay,
and so they then,
during this they move towards the beach
and here we go.
It was dusk.
When we reached the beach,
we saw a wrecked and smoking ships,
a clean on shipped expanse of water between Guadalcanal and Florida island.
Our Navy was gone.
Gone.
Yeah,
so
if you don't know anything about the Pacific campaign,
you're taking down islands
and your lifeline is the navy because that's who's going to bring you
ammunition,
food,
water,
gun support,
fire support.
That's where you're going to take your casualties.
So you have total reliance on the navy.
And these guys wake up in the morning and the Navy's gone other than sunken
ships.
Horrible.
And what can they do?
There's nowhere to run to.
You can't back.
We can't.
There's nowhere to go.
But Navy is gone.
So they get ordered to take a position where they think an attack might come
from.
And here we go.
Back to the book,
we were ordered up from the beach,
two new positions on the West Bank of the tenor rule river.
Our orders commanded us to urgency.
The enemy was expected.
The 10 rule river laid green and evil like a serpent across the palm.
He coastal plain,
it was called a river,
but it was not a river like most of the streams of Oceana.
It was a creek,
not 30 yards wide.
So they're placed there to set security and they're there for a while.
And finally one night here we go back to the book a man says of the eruption of
battle,
all hell broke loose the first time he says it.
It is true,
wonderfully descriptive.
The millionth time.
It has said it has been worn into meaninglessness.
It has gone the way of all good phrasing.
It has become cliche,
but within five minutes of that first machine gun burst of the appearance of
that first enemy flare that suffused the battlefield and honestly Greenough
greenish light and by its dying accentuated the redeveloping night.
Within five minutes of this,
all hell broke loose.
Everyone was firing.
Every weapon was sounding voice,
but this was no orchestration,
no terribly beautiful symphony,
symphony of death as decadent rear echelon observers,
right here was a cacophony.
Here was a cacophony.
Here was dissonance.
Here was wildness.
He was the absence of rhythm,
the loss of limit for fires.
What?
When and where he chooses here was booming sounding,
shrinking,
wailing,
hissing,
crashing,
shaking,
jibberish noise here was hell.
Yet each weapon had its own sound and it is odd with what clarity.
The trained ear distinguishes each one and catalogs it plucks it out of the
genital din.
Even though it is intermingled with coincidental with the voice of a dozen
others,
even though one's own machine guns spits and coughs and dances and shakes and
cleric fury.
So it was that our ears pricked prickled at strange new sounds,
the lighter shingles snapping crack of the Japanese rifle,
the gargle of,
they're extremely fast machine guns,
the hiccup of their light mortars.
And by the way,
the movie the Pacific or the,
the series that Pacific shows the battle scenes of the tender we river and
they're phenomenal.
They do a great job of representing what's just what he's talking about right
there.
Back to the book,
we dive for our,
our holes and gun positions.
I jumped the gun,
I jumped the gun with which chocolate and I had left standing on the bank.
I unclamp the gun and fired spraying my shots as though air handling a hose.
All but one fell.
The first fell as though his underpart had been cut from him by a Skype and the
others fell tumbling,
screaming.
Once again,
our gun collapsed and I grabbed a rifle.
I remember it had no sling,
which had been left near the gun.
The jap who had survived,
who had survived was deep into the coconuts.
By the time I found him in the rifle sites,
there was his back bobbing large and he seemed to be throwing his pack away.
Then I fired and he wasn't there anymore.
Perhaps it was not I who shot him,
but everyone had found their senses for,
not everyone had found their senses and their weapons by then,
but I boasted that I had perhaps too,
it was a merciful bullet that pounded him between the shoulder blades for,
he was fleeing to a certain and horrible end Black Knights hunger and slow
dissolution in the rain forest,
but I had not thought of mercy.
Then modern war went forward in the jungle.
Men of the first battalion were cleaning up.
Sometimes they drove a Japanese toward us.
He would cower on the river bank,
hiding on aware that opposite him where we already the victors.
Numerous,
heavily armed.
Lusting for more blood.
Yeah.
We killed a few more this way.
Yeah,
the fever was on us
yet.
It's interesting in that he's looking back and thinking to himself that when he
kills this Japanese soldier,
that that was a merciful thing to do because he,
they've been suffered yet.
They've been on the island for a few days,
even though they're scared,
even though they receive fire,
they haven't gone to the full length of suffering that they're going to go
through.
So when the over
and Leckie gives everyone in the book,
he just gives them these really kind of easy to understand nicknames based on
their personality.
So he talks about this guy here who he calls Lieutenant Ivy League,
which doesn't take a lot of explanation to picture what that guy is like.
So here we go back to the book Lieutenant Ivy League strode up to our pits in
the morning.
So this is the battle's over.
He sat on a coconut log and told us what had happened.
He smoked desperately and stared into the river.
As he talked,
the skin around his eyes was drawn tight with strain and with shock.
His eyes had already taken on that aspect.
Peculiar to Guadalcanal,
that constant stare of pupils that seemed darker,
larger,
rounder,
more.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Did he kind of gives them a debrief on what happened with the battle that where
the Japanese had come from and then he says,
when he spoke again,
it was to tell us who had been killed.
There were more than a dozen from age company besides more than a score of
wounded.
Four or five of the dead were from our platoon.
Tune with them had been hacked to death.
A Japanese scouting party had found them asleep in their whole on the river bank
and slice them into pieces.
Okay.
Our regimen had killed something like 900 of them.
Most of them lay in clusters or an heaps before the gun pits,
commanding the sand spit as though they had not died singly,
but in groups,
one of the Marines went methodically among the dead.
Armed with a pair of pliers.
He had observed that the Japanese have a penchant for gold fillings in their
teeth,
often for solid gold teeth.
He was looting.
They're very mouth's.
He would kick their jaws,
agape peer into the mouth with all the solicitude of a park avenue dentist.
Careful,
always careful not to contaminate himself by touch and Yank out all the
glittered you kept the gold teeth and an empty bull.
Durham Tobacco Sac,
which he wore around his neck.
Okay.
Souvenirs,
we called him.
That's another nickname he gives.
They get,
they called this guy souvenirs.
Now
they're holding in that position and,
and for a few nights while they were holding this position on the river,
they would see,
they didn't know what it was.
They would see sort of a v in the calm water.
They would see like a v a disturbance in the water and they couldn't figure out
what it was.
They were scared out of the couple of times they shot towards it.
They didn't know what it was.
I thought it was a spy or,
or uh,
a scout trying to check them out,
but they were crocodiles.
Okay.
Back to the book.
I took the glasses from him and focused on the opposite shore where I saw a
crocodile eating the fat Japanese.
I watched and debased fascination.
But when the crocodile began to tug the intestines,
I recalled my own presence in that very river hardly an hour ago,
and my knees went weak and I relinquished the glasses that night.
The v reappeared in the wherever,
so they could see that the little ripple in the river or everyone whooped and
hollered,
no one fired.
We knew what it was.
It was the crocodile three smaller V's trailed afterwards,
so there's even more crocodiles coming.
They kept us awake,
crunching the smell kept us awake.
Even though we lay with our heads swath and a blanket,
which was now,
which was how he kept off the mosquitoes.
The smell overpowered us,
smell the sense which somehow seems a joke is the one most susceptible to
outrage.
It will give you no rest.
One can close one's eyes to ugliness or shields the ears from sound,
but from a powerful smell,
there is no recourse but flight than since we could not flee,
we could not escape this smell and we could not sleep.
We never fired at the crocodiles.
They return to the repast day after day until the remains were removed to mass
burning and burial,
which served as a funeral pyre for the enemy.
We had denial dated
our victory in the fight,
which we called.
The Battle of Hell's point was not so great as we had imagined it to be.
It was to be,
but one of the many fights for Guadalcanal and in the end,
not the foremost of them,
but being the first in our experience,
we took it for total triumph like those who take the present for the best of all
worlds,
having no reference to the past nor regard for the future.
Okay?
It's a mistake we all make.
You know something good happens and you think you think you're the victor
[inaudible] from the high plateau of triumph.
We were about to descend into the depths of trial and tedium.
The Japanese attack was to be redoubled and prolonged in varied.
It would come from the sky,
the sea,
and the land.
In between every trial there would stretch out the tedium that sucks.
A man dry drawing off the juice from body and soul as a native removes the
contents of a stick of sugar cane leaving.
It spent cracked good for nothing but the flames.
And there is terror coming from the interaction of trial and tedium,
the first shaking a and as the wind and the tree tops the second eroding him as
the flood at the roots.
So he's got these two things that are working on him.
Trial,
which is the,
the actual fighting,
the actual attacks and tedium,
which is the boredom and the waiting.
And again,
if you watch the Pacific,
it does a great job of showing this in.
One of the things that really got me when I watched that for the first time is
it shows this landing and there's nothing happening.
Then you're waiting for it to happen.
The new,
you know what's going to happen and you're waiting for it.
And that was a real,
that that,
that I remember that feeling of being in the streets and you're waiting for to
happen and you're just waiting and it's a,
you want it to happen because then you can go,
let's get it over with.
Yeah,
but here's what he's describing it as like a tree being eroded.
So the first shaking a man as the wind in the tree tops the second.
So that's,
that's what,
that's what the,
the actual thing does to chase you around.
But the tedium,
the second,
that's the tedium eroding him as the flood at the roots.
Each fresh trial leaves a man more shaken than the last and each period of
tedium with it's time for speculative dread
leaves.
His foundations worn lower,
his woots less from for the next trial.
Sometimes there is a final shattering.
A man crouching in a pit beneath the bombardment of a battleship might put a
pistol to his head and deliver himself.
Sometimes it is partial,
but another man might break at the sound of a diving enemy plane and scream and
shutter and wring his hands and rise to run.
This is the terror I meant.
This is the terror,
that strangles reason with the clawing hands of panic.
I saw it twice.
I felt it pluck at me twice,
but it was rare.
It claimed few victims,
so,
so that's a really,
I think that's just a phenomenal way to understand what these guys were going
through.
The waiting and then the trial and then the waiting and then the trial.
And that's a great description.
Speculative,
dread.
Just just thinking about,
okay,
what's the next attack going to be like?
Are we going to be able to get through it?
Okay.
And you know,
he's talking about guys killed themselves.
Yeah.
Being so they just can't take it any more.
They can't take it anymore and
okay.
The only way out they can figure is to kill themselves,
which is just,
it's horrible,
horrible,
thick love times criminals will do that.
Like if they're on there,
like fugitive,
if they're on the run crew.
Yeah.
And they're like,
when are they going to break down my door and find me?
And they get that speculative dread and they just turned themselves in.
Right.
Or I thought you were going to say that sometimes,
you know guys wants,
they're surrounded by the Swat team.
Oh yeah,
that happens.
Then there's just no,
there's,
they just can't take any more of that give themselves,
yeah,
I feel like that's more of them.
Like I'd rather die than go to jail almost sure thing.
But true speculative tread there.
You're talking about it.
Yeah.
Even in like did you the tournaments,
you know when you're winning around like Oh am I up,
am I up?
That's like can be part of the chat.
I mean waiting.
Yeah.
I mean obviously way more lighthearted than this,
but you know this and he,
so he says this and he says it,
he claimed few victims,
meaning it didn't actually,
most guys sucked it up and you're going to hear him.
You know,
cause he says he felt it.
Yeah.
Twice.
It plucked at him twice
but it wasn't,
it was rare.
He says it but it was rare.
And then he says courage was commonplace.
Okay.
Cause that was what was normal.
What was normal was courage.
And this is just such a good paragraph or two here.
Courage was,
was a commonplace.
It formed a club or corporation much as do those other common things upon which
men for diverse reasons place so great.
A value like money,
like charity four,
it is in the common on which the exclusive rests.
Okay
are muddy machine.
Gun Pits were transformed into courage clubs when bombs fell or Japanese
warships pounded us from the sea.
There was protocol to be observed too and it was natural that the poor fellow
who might break into momentary terror should cause pain silences and embarrassed
coughs.
Everyone looked the other way,
like millionaires confronted by the horrifying sight of a club member borrowing
$5 from the waiter.
Yeah,
and then he says this,
but there was a bit more charity in our clubs I think.
Yeah.
We were not quite so puffed up that we could not recognize the ugly thing on our
friend's face as the elder brother.
Okay.
Of the thing fluttering within our own inner.
Okay,
you today?
Me Tomorrow.
Okay.
And such a powerful
thing to think about when you see someone going through some trouble to be able
to recognize like,
hey guys,
you know,
Echo's going through some issues right now and I'm not looking down at you.
I'm not judging you.
I'm recognizing that what you're going through today could be what I go through
tomorrow.
And they all felt,
he felt that,
you know,
I see echo losing it and curling into a ball and not wanting to fight.
And I recognize that as the older brother of the thing that I actually feel too.
But I've got it under control today.
Tomorrow I might not,
but today I got under control.
That's why I'm not looking down my nose at you.
And that's why I'm not judging you.
And I think that forms such a tight bond that these guys had,
you know,
these guys had respect enough respect and enough mercy on each other to say,
look,
echoes goes having a hard time right now.
It's okay,
we're going to get him through today.
I'm not going to look down on him in tomorrow.
It might be me.
And he's not going to look down on me.
Yeah.
Powerful stuff.
We tend to judge.
Yeah.
Especially,
yeah,
it seems like they so they can relate,
you know,
like echoes at level eight right now.
He's losing it.
I'm over here at level two.
Yep.
And Luckily I can keep the two inside,
you know?
Yeah.
But I don't even know when two's going to be four tables at one,
so I could very well be it,
you know?
But then why idea that when you're dealing with other people you try and have
their perspective.
You try and take their perspective and understand what they're going through and
have empathy for what's happening to them.
Powerful.
Yeah,
man.
Instead we tend so often just did want to judge.
Yeah.
Judge,
back to the book at night washing machine,
Charlie picked up the slack washing machine,
washing machine.
Charlie so named for the sound of his motors was the nocturnal marauder who
proud our skies.
So these are Japanese bombers,
like the dog who's bark is worse than its bite.
The throb of Charlie's motors was more fearsome than thump of his bombs.
Charlie did not kill many people,
but like Macbeth,
he murdered sleep to these trials was added the worst ordeal,
shelling from the sea enemy warships,
usually cruisers.
Sometimes battleships stand off your coast.
It is night and you cannot see them,
nor could you.
If it were day as they're miles and miles away,
we could see the flashes of the guns far out to sea.
We heard the soft papoose,
a boom of their salvos.
Then rushing through the night,
straining an airy
boxcar came the huge projectiles,
the earth rocks and shakes upon the terrifying crash of the detonation.
Though it'd be hundreds of yards away.
Your stomach is squeezed as though a monster,
a monster hand.
We're needing it into dough.
You,
Greg,
gasp for breath.
Like a football player who falls heavily and as the wind knocked out of him,
flash,
boom,
they're lowing their sites.
It's coming closer.
Oh,
that one was close.
The sandbags are falling.
I can't hear it.
I can't hear the shell.
It's the one you don't hear.
They say the one you don't hear.
Where is it?
Flash pop boob.
Thank God it's lifted.
It's going the other way.
It's daylight now and they're only the bombings to worry about and the heat and
the mosquitoes and the rice line in our bellies like stones.
So again,
the the unknown and uncontrollable experience of getting hit with mortars or
artillery or in this case naval gunfire.
And again,
there's no u US navy out there.
They're just having their way.
It's a nightmare.
They continue to press on,
but things are not looking good.
Back to the book,
everyone kept saying,
hopefully that the army was coming in next week to relieve us.
Everyone was in despair.
We heard that the army relief force had been destroyed at see chocolate and I
visited the cemetery.
It laid to the south off the coastal road that ran from east to west through the
coconuts.
We knelt to pray before the graves of the men.
We had known only palm fronds marked a place where they were buried,
although here,
and there were rude crosses on which were nailed.
The men's identification tags,
some of the crosses,
Bor mess gear,
tins of fixed to the wood,
like rude medallions and on those the marines had lovingly carved they're
epitaphs.
He died fighting a real marine,
a big guy with a bigger heart.
Our buddy,
the harder the going,
the morph cheerful he was.
There was also this verse which I had seen countless times before and since the
direct and unpolished cry of a marine,
sardonic heart and when he gets to heaven,
so Saint Peter,
he will tell one more marine reporting,
sir,
I've served my time and hell
yeah.
Now part of that,
part of that,
okay,
despair that they felt came from the fact that they began to feel
expendable.
Then he goes into that.
Here all armies have expendable items that is a part or unit the destruction of
which will not be fatal to the whole in some more deals,
a man might consider his finger expendable,
but not his hand or extremity.
His arm,
but not as hard.
There are expendable items which may be lost or destroyed in the field,
either in war or peace without their owner being required to replace them.
A rifle is so expendable or a cartridge belt.
So are men.
Men are the most expendable of all hunger.
The jungle,
the Japanese,
not one,
nor all of these could be quite as corrosive as the feeling of expandability.
This was no feeling of dedication because it was absolutely involuntary.
I do not doubt Betty for marines had asked for volunteers for an impossible
campaigns such as Guadalcanal,
almost everyone.
Now fighting would've stepped forward.
But that is sacrifice.
That is voluntary being expended robs you of that x saltation the self
abnegation the absolute freedom of self sacrifice being expended puts one in the
role of victim rather than sacrifice her.
And there was always something begrudging in this.
So
yeah,
luckily they do end up
getting some help,
getting relieved.
The army shows up to help him out and here we go.
So we were glad to see the soldiers when they came trudging up to our pits.
They came after another air rate,
a very close one.
But the thing had not infected them yet.
War was still a lark.
Their faces were still heavy with flesh.
Their ribs padded,
their eyes innocent.
They were older than we an averaged 25 to our average 20 yet we treated them
like children.
Now even though they get relieved,
they're working and still fighting and they're still suffering.
Back to the book we were growing erodible our strength was being steadily sapped
and a sort of physical depression afflicted.
Many of us.
Okay.
The rain,
the rainy season was upon us on our exposed rich.
It fell upon us and Torrance,
a man was drenched in seconds.
His teeth chattering in his hands darting swiftly to his precious cigarettes,
transferring them to the safety of his helmet liner,
cursing bitterly if he'd waited too long before becoming conscious of their
peril.
After cigarettes,
we were concerned about our ammunition on the downward slope of the hill.
The rain water ran into our pits and holes as though they were sewer receivers.
We had to dash for the pits and lift the boxes and machine gun belts out of the
water's way,
piling them a top one another on the earth and gun platform.
Any dry place in the pit was reserved for ammunition.
He who sought refuge from the rain had to sit on the water cans.
Okay.
There were whole days of downpour where I lay drenched and shivering grade
gazing blankly out of my whole watching is the sheet at gray,
rain whipped and any undulated over the ridge.
Okay.
At such times,
a man's brain seems to cease to function.
It seems to retreat into a depth much as the red core puzzles retreat from the
surface of the body in times of excitement.
Okay.
One ceases to be rational.
One becomes only sediment,
like a barnacle clinging onto a ship.
Yeah.
One is aware only of life of wetness of the cold gray rain,
but without this automatic retreat of reasons a man can go only one way.
He can only go mad.
Certain level of detachment there.
Just checking out,
just checking out.
You're just there,
but you're not there.
Good place too.
It's a good place to visit sometimes,
you know?
I don't think you want to live there.
You certainly don't want to live there,
but it's a good place to visit.
Why?
I just think,
I think it's important to get to a point where you're just detaching from your
physical suffering and your physical pain and you just say,
you know what?
I'm just turned off and you just retreat.
Like he said,
you just retreat into almost like nothingness.
I think it's important maybe to gain clarity or something.
Yeah.
I think you gained some clarity and I think it's a,
I think it's a very important defense mechanism to have.
Oh yeah,
you don't,
you sometimes when you're doing stuff,
you just have to do it like you can't think about it anymore.
You just have to turn your brain off and go,
and I think that's what,
that's what he's talking about right there.
He's not,
he's not participating in it.
He's just detaching from it and doing what he's got to.
His body is doing what he's got to do.
Huh.
Now
they
there.
There's this whole time they're expecting to be relieved.
They're expecting to get the get pulled off the island and one of the sergeants
comes out and makes an announcement to them stand by to move out in the morning.
Yeah,
we moving out into a new offensive,
get all your foul weather gear ready and be Sure Your Gun's is oiled up and the
ammunition belts dry eight marines will be up to relieve us in the morning.
So they,
they,
they think they're going to get relieved and go to a ship and relax and get,
get,
get into,
get some relief.
That's what we're leave is right,
but they get told,
no,
you're going on a new offensive.
So they're in,
well here,
going back to the book after nearly five months,
by the way,
a lot of times you think of the island campaigns,
Japan,
these are little live ones,
you know,
10 miles long.
You think all that probably took a week,
two weeks,
five months after nearly five months.
This runner,
and he's going to name all of the different guys at different nicknames.
You can hear him.
Runner had malaria,
brick barely stirred from the pit except at night.
Who's you're an oak stump.
We're subject to long periods of depression.
Red had long since left us.
I had dysentery.
Chocolatier was irritable.
All of us were emaciated and weakened beyond measure,
but we were to move out on the attack.
We could not move to chow without gasping for breath,
but we were to move on the enemy.
We despaired in the morning.
We crouched by our guns and waited for the order to dismantle them and move out.
It did not come,
nor did it come the next day or the next and hope came creeping back.
Blushing,
ashamed of her.
Loyal dis offer.
Disloyal flight,
but commending herself to us once more with the promise.
Never again to desert the ramparts.
Then one morning the word came to move out.
Sergeant Dandy gave it to us.
Leave the guns behind.
He said,
take only your rifles and foul weather geared.
He grinned.
We're being relieved.
It was December 14th,
1942 we had been on the lines without relief since August 7th my battalion,
the second battalion first regimen was the last of those in the First Marine
Division to come out of a lines.
Guadalcanal was over.
We had one
next,
he's,
they get
pulled back off the island now and he's climbing aboard the ship of the board.
Cargo Nets.
He's exhausted.
I was able to reach the top of the net book could go no further.
I could not muster the strength to swing over the gunnel.
And I hung their breathing heavily.
The ship's hot side swing away from me in the swells.
The very perdition lapping beneath me until two sailors grabbed me or to the
armpits and pulled me over.
I fell with a clatter among the others who had been so broad a board and I lay
with my cheek pressed against a warm,
grimy deck.
My heart beating rapidly.
Not from this exercise,
but from happiness.
Yeah.
And he ends up having a sailor,
a conversation.
Him and his buddy chocolate,
who's like one of his best friends,
they,
they are end up having a conversation
with one of the sailors.
And you said the soldier seems surprised.
He says,
you mean Guadalcanal?
The guy says at,
was it rough?
How was it?
Rough.
We answered mechanically.
Then chocolate spoke up.
You Mean Guadalcanal?
The soldier seem surprised.
Sorry.
The conversation with the soldier that was on the ship that hadn't been to
Guadalcanal.
The soldiers seem surprised.
Of course I do.
Chocolate hasten to explain.
I wasn't being wise.
I meant,
had you ever heard of the place before you got here?
His astonishment startled us and idea was dawning.
You mean how yes,
Guadalcanal the first marines.
Everybody's heard of it.
You guys are famous.
You guys are heroes back home.
We did not see him leave for,
we had both looked away quickly,
each embarrassed by the quick tiers.
They had not forgotten.
And
again,
I kind of breezed through that part in,
in the book.
But a lot of times when they were in those moments of despair,
they'd be thinking,
no one knows what's going on here.
They don't know how bad at this,
but the reality was was this,
this war or this battle that lasted five months,
there was all kinds of reporting and the glory of the f of the Marines and what
they were doing.
And so they were,
I guess they were just overwhelmed with the fact that this,
this soldier had said,
you guys,
are you kidding me?
Guadalcanal?
This is it.
Now after they leave Guadalcanal,
they,
it's some much needed r and r
rest and they'd get to
go to Australia to do this.
And they,
they go into the book of all the regimens.
Ours,
the first was in the most advantageous position for the great Dibaj discipline
already dissolved in the delicious squeals of the girls all but disappeared that
night.
We'd received part of our six months arrears of PE in Australian pounds,
but we were issued no clothing.
We still wore our disheveled dungaree.
So you can imagine these guys are coming off of Guadalcanal hell and now they're
rolling into Australia and,
and they describe it here.
The girls are waiting for them.
These are the heroes of Guadalcanal.
So they roll in and they get after it in the way that we talked about earlier.
They start,
they start just do there.
They're going crazy.
And He,
and this is one of them,
one of the things I loved about this book is that this,
that Robert Lecky is so real.
He's so real.
He's just a,
he's just real.
And,
and guess what he likes to do?
He likes to get after it.
He goes out,
he drinks,
they drink,
they chase women,
he goes hard.
And YG ends up getting in some,
getting a little bit into some trouble.
And he talks about bring rats,
basically guys that have been thrown in the Brig,
which is,
which is the military jail.
And on a ship they actually have a little break,
you know,
little jail room and you can get thrown in there.
And so he talks a little bit about that.
It is most especially a marine sediment sentiment.
And when analyzed,
it turns out to be not shameless or shocking,
but merely this,
a man who lands in the brig is apt to be a man of bold spirit and independent
mind.
Who must occasionally rebel against the harsh and unrelenting disciplined of the
camp.
I'm not attempting to exalt what should be condemned.
I'm not suggesting that because of their boldness or independence,
the brig rats be per be forgiven and escape punishment,
Briggs,
they must be and Briggs,
they were.
Nor Am I.
Speaking of the Habitual Brig Rat,
the steady Maliner who the good for nothing,
who is more often in the brig then out of it and who seeks to avoid every
consequence of his uniform.
Even fighting,
I speak of the young high hearted soldier whose very nature is bound to bring
him into conflict with military discipline and a land him,
unless he's exceptionally lucky in the Brig I speak of chocolate and chicken and
oak stump and a dozen others
and of course of myself.
So he's saying,
look,
you got guys that are high spirited go getters and they're gonna,
they're gonna get after it on the battlefield and they're going to get after it
on liberty and sometimes they're going to get rolled up unless they're super
lucky and that doesn't make them bad people.
And I had one of my buddies get in really big trouble.
This is when we were young guys
back in the day,
one of my Bros,
he got in big trouble.
And I thought that our officer,
who's one of the best officers I ever worked for,
I thought he was going to really be,
you know,
just crushed him.
And,
and I thought he's going to be really disappointed in all of these horrible
things.
And this is the guy,
the officer was a guy that we all loved and wanted to always impress and we want
to do good job for it.
So when my buddy had this big incident that he did,
which,
you know,
he was drunk and got crazy and you know,
got arrested and all that,
all that bad stuff.
And I talked to our OIC about it and I said,
hey sir,
you know,
I mean,
what's going to happen with my buddy?
And the officer goes,
Hey,
you guys are young warriors and things like this are going to happen.
Don't let them happen much,
but they're going to happen and we'll deal with it.
And I will send myself,
I wonder why I love this guy so much.
But that's,
that's exactly it.
You know,
he was,
he knew that,
that,
you know,
you had young,
rambunctious guys full of testosterone and then you add alcohol into the
equation and you add chaos into the equation because some guys might get in
trouble again,
I hate to,
to give that credence to this type of stuff.
Cause when I look back,
I wish I would've been a better leader.
I wish I would have been doing other things,
you know?
But if you're in a leadership position and you've got guys like this and you
condemn them,
instead of trying to help them,
you're not helping them.
It goes back to this judgment thing that we talked about earlier.
If I'm looking at you saying,
oh,
you don't,
uh,
you got in trouble.
You're a bad person.
I don't want you on this team.
Instead of saying,
hey look,
we got to get you under control.
You've got the right attitude.
You've got the lot of energy.
Let's focus it on somewhere.
Correct.
Let's focus it on something good.
Let's get you doing something positive instead of doing something negative
instead.
Sometimes guys go to the judgmental mode,
you know,
I'm just gonna judge you and Oh,
you got in trouble,
so you're bad.
That's the wrong attitude to have.
And how about you got in trouble?
How bout me as the leader,
I let you down.
I didn't show you the right way to expend your energy.
I didn't give you the opportunity to give you an outlet for this.
This aggression that you have because you are aggression,
you're going to have,
that means fighting you.
You don't think you get up.
You get a guys that are in the military.
You want someone in your platoon.
Do you want them to be not aggressive?
Of course you want be,
I want the most aggressive bastards you can imagine.
And guess what?
If you don't give them something to do with that aggression,
they're going to find something to do with it and is not going to be good.
So as a leader,
let's find something positive we can that they can do with their aggression.
Yeah.
It's not like he's out there and not like it's known.
You know,
like in your case you,
you,
you thought he was going to get severely punished,
you know,
so it's like,
it's not like he's out there publicly say nay.
That's cool dude.
You got to do player.
Right.
But when it happened,
yeah,
it's like,
and I think truly that officer who is a great guy,
he truly probably felt exactly what I just said.
I should have given them a better outlet for this aggression.
You know,
I should have let,
I should have figured something better out for them to do.
We gotta do something.
You give us idle hands and pockets full of money.
Can you imagine these guys are getting six month pay enrollment.
They were the richest guys in the world.
I guarantee it.
You know,
especially you rolling into wartime Australia.
I mean,
you know how stringent they were with,
with the restricting the money that people were using and spending all over the
world to save money for the war.
And here come these guys in richest guys ever heroes,
a qual of canal.
They're going to get after it,
they're going to get after it.
So as leaders,
what we need to do is give them a proper outlet because those guys want to get
after it.
But when you got to give him the right way,
you know,
you gotta give them something positive that they can work on.
And if you're going to let them do something negative,
then let's put some barriers around them so they don't get into trouble.
Yeah.
Wish I would've known this when I was at,
when I was coming up,
I would have done more positive stuff instead of more negative stuff.
So now we get the trouble piece and these,
he's got so many great stories about how these guys,
what these guys were going through and this,
so they're out.
He's out drinking in one of his buddies,
a guy that I mentioned before,
his name is chocolate chocolate is actually on duty.
So He's,
he's standing duty,
which means he's in uniform,
he's not allowed to drink,
he's watching and he's been,
you know,
he,
he's,
he's on duty.
And so here we go.
I found chocolatier standing glumly outside the slop shoot entrance.
He'd hope for the interior guard where he might sneak a beer or two.
I'll get you one.
I promised I returned with a big glass out of which chocolate might take a
surreptitious sip.
There were more side ELLs until Chutler said I got to go to the head here,
cover for me.
He gave me his pistol belt and helmet and made off.
So now Lech he's drunk right now.
You're okay.
So
but,
but chocolate says,
hey man,
I gotta take a Piss here,
take my helmet,
take my pistol cover for me
first century to be drunk.
And then dessert
as post and surrender as a weapon is to combine cardinal sin with unforgivable
offence.
I was anxiously hoping that he would hurry back.
But then an unfortunate thing happened,
Lieutenant Ivy League came striding down the corridor.
I say it was unfortunate because Ivy League was the officer of the day.
More than that,
he was still the man who had filched my cigars,
the enlisted men cigars,
if you will.
So at one point he had gotten ahold of some cigars and this officer had taken
him.
And by the way,
also,
you know,
uh,
Robert Lucky he's an Irishman and I'm not going to,
you know,
make a generalization.
Okay?
Yes I am.
He's a hot tempered Irishman.
And so he sees this,
he sees this guy and it then he's drunk.
He just got off of Guadalcanal.
And here's what happens.
Back to the book,
my anger was nourished by the alcohol within me and I drew chocolates pistol and
pointed at him and said,
stop where you are you lousy cigar stealing son of a bitch or I'll blow your
gentleman's ass off.
So
not,
not good.
And he ends up getting in pretty significant trouble and he actually gets bread
and water,
which they still do that in the military.
They get bread and water you can get,
he gets bread and water for five days.
So in the break,
bread and water for five days,
that's,
that's the punishment that he gets.
And he gets docked pay and he gets the busted down.
In Rick,
one time I was on a ship deployed Brooklyn,
a jury and we were in a seal platoon.
And I think after I've told the story before,
it was the one where the marines,
like we would stay on the ship when we pulled into port and it would,
it would take like an hour to get off the ship because everyone would be waiting
in line.
And so what we would do is we would just work out for that hour,
hour and a half,
and then would have golf.
We could just walk right off the ship.
Well,
in that hour and a half,
the marine,
this,
this young marine had gone off the ship and was getting carried back onto the
ship,
like passed out drunk,
covered in puke in an hour and a half.
So that's what I think of when I think of these poor guys.
Can you come out and coming off of Guadalcanal?
You haven't even had water for six months.
Nevermind alcohol.
It's a nightmare.
But,
and of course they don't punish him too bad.
Well,
they,
they punish him,
but they got to keep him,
you know,
I mean,
he's an able body marine.
They're not going to,
if they're not going to waste an able body marine.
And hopefully the colonel and the back of his mind was thinking himself,
you know what,
I want this guy in my don't want this guy with me.
You know,
this guy that's just going to,
you stole cigars from me.
Cool.
I'm going to,
I'm not threatened your life just getting nuts.
So they,
but now Australia ends,
they roll back out and it's time for them to start getting prepared to,
they go to,
they go to New Guinea and if you remember New Guinea,
it's another hard battles fought there primarily by the Australians and
underdose primarily.
But the Australians definitely fought because I read that letter from the
Australian soldier to his two year old daughter.
That's where he died,
was in New Guinea.
But now new Guinea is,
is owned by the allies and they'd go there to train to start to prepare for
their next big push.
And here we go.
Back to the book,
the Chuck climbed a series of small hills and finally deposited us in the middle
of a field of Kunai grass,
our new home.
This is how the marines trained their men.
Keep them mean and nasty like starving beasts says the core.
And they will fight better when men are being moved from one place to another.
Spare no effort to make it painful.
And before they've arrived at their destination,
dispatch a man ahead to survey the ground with an eye toward diff discomfort.
So you hear this all the time that that's what the Marine Corps,
the Marine Corps is going to make you so pissed off.
By the time you go into battle,
you're just gonna kill everybody because you're so sick of living in the dirt.
Now they do a decent amount of training and now they're preparing to assault
another island called new Britain.
And this is,
I found this very interesting.
So
back to the book,
the commander called us together that night and delivered an eve of battle
speech.
He spoke in deliberate but angry tones.
He spoke like a man who hated the Japanese as though he had suffered a personal
affront at their hands and was bent on personal vengeance as though this worry
personal,
not mechanical war.
His harangue seemed unreal.
It was unreal because it could never produce the desired effect.
Kill the Japs.
The commander was saying,
I want you to kill Japs and I want you to remember that your marines,
we've got a tough job where we're going and where we're going.
You won't have much room for ammunition,
so you'd better be sure you see something before you shoot.
Don't squeeze the trigger until you've got meat and your sites and when you do
spill blood spill yeller blood,
that was all we walked back to the tense.
It was Christmas Eve and I find this,
it's Christmas Eve.
He gets this speech and you can see like he's sitting here if this thinking,
okay,
this guy's trying to get them all riled up and it's not having any impact
and this is what I found to be a real dichotomy here at the tents.
Okay.
Father's straight was preparing to say midnight mass.
So they have a chaplain,
Catholic chaplain,
father straight,
and here's what he says.
Father's straight spoke gently.
He reminded us that not all of us would live to see another Christmas that
perhaps some of us might die this very day.
He told us to be sorry for our sins,
to ask the forgiveness of God,
to forgive those who have wronged us,
to prepare our souls for death.
We sang hymns.
Okay.
1,940 odd years ago.
The baby had been born in Bethlehem and we celebrated him this night in a dark
and misty forest that his father had wrought.
We sang him.
Okay.
We sang hymns to him.
Yeah.
Silent night and Hark.
The Herald Angels Sing Mild.
He lays his glory by born that man no more may die.
Okay,
Dan.
Tomorrow our hands would be stained with the blood of our brothers,
but we sang on halfheartedly half hoping we sometimes mechanically,
sometimes with a desperate driving poignancy.
Okay,
one hand on the heart,
the other on the hilt of a bayonet
in the morning we marched down to the ships.
So much more impactful on him was what father straight and much more than the
fiery kernel that said,
we're going to go kill jabs here.
These guys are,
yeah,
I mean,
can you imagine you go in for comfort to midnight mass Christmas Eve and you get
told
that
many people,
many of you may die this very day and to prepare your soul for death,
that's what these guys are facing.
That's what their most trusted,
the most trusted person in our lives,
right?
Their spiritual counselor is telling them,
prepare for death
yet kinda like Kinda like what we talk about sometimes where
get a guy,
like if you're watching a video,
you know and it's the guy getting you fired up.
You know he's getting fired up to get you fired up.
Sometimes it could work,
but a lot of times that won't really work cause you kind of feel like he's
trying to sell you something.
But then if you hear someone,
maybe even talking to someone else or talking about something else and you just
kind of extrapolate certain things that get you fired up because it's so
authentic and it's basically the indirect approach on your own mind.
Yeah.
On your mind.
Yes.
Back to the book on the sunless shores of new Britain where the rain forest
crowded steeply down to the sea.
We have the first marine division came back to the assault and it was here that
we cut the Japanese to pieces.
Literally when that devouring jungle did not dissolve them and it was here that
we pitied them
now to pay enemy is either madness or is it a sign or it is a sign of strength.
I think that with the First Marine Division on new Britain,
it was a sign of strength.
We pitied him in the end,
this fleeing fold,
disorganized,
demoralized,
crawling on hands and knees.
Even in that desolving downpour
for in the end
it was we the soft of feet Americans who had learned to get along in the jungle
and who bore up the best beneath the ordeal of the monsoon and in these things
lay our strength.
And I'll tell you what I think that boils down to.
So what they're saying,
here's the,
you know the Americans,
what it,
what do people around the world think of the Americans even in 1943 Americans
are soft,
Americans are lazy Americans,
they have their too much comfort and you think the exact opposite of the
Japanese,
especially in World War II,
the imperial Japanese army,
it was highly disciplined.
It was extremely strict.
It was a spartan lifestyle.
But look at what happened here and why is that.
And I'll tell you why in my opinion,
I will tell you why.
Because you have men that are fighting for freedom,
they're fighting for freedom and that makes all the difference in the world.
Fighting for individual freedom,
fighting for their personal freedom and fighting for their nation's freedom and
fighting for their nation's freedom.
And it's a nation that is based upon freedom.
That right there is stronger than any
tyrannical
government or any fanatical idea.
The idea of freedom is stronger than the mall and that is why these quote soft
Americans.
That is why they were able to conquer and defeat this enemy,
this hardened enemy,
this well-trained enemy
and this talks a little bit about what we were facing.
Yeah.
To the north.
One patrol discovered the body of an he company scout who had been reported
missing the area,
bore the marks of a struggle as though we had fought hand to hand his body board
dozens of bayonet net wounds.
They had used him for bayonet practice
in his mouth.
They had stuffed flesh.
They had cut from his arm.
His buddy said he had a tattoo there,
the marine emblem,
the fouled anchor and the globe.
The Japs cut it off and stuffed it in his mouth.
Okay.
The commander was angry
again to the north to Japanese officers had been caught snooping around our
positions and had been killed.
Okay.
An e company outposts,
scouting the terrain at their front had discovered a Japanese force in platoons,
strength,
sleeping,
sleeping on the ground,
sleeping.
They fired into them,
into these sleeping superman of the jungle.
Okay.
Withdrawing upon the approach of another enemy platoon.
And after this,
after the bulk of the battle takes place,
and it was a fair,
it was,
it was not a fair fight and you're about to find out why.
Back to the book for Japanese soldiers and one officer had been taken alive,
that he'd been brought down to the CP,
their arms bound behind them,
knives at their throats,
and from them we learned that the third company,
53rd Regiment of the Japanese 17th division had been dispatched from the main
body at Cape Gloucester to defend against our landing.
Their passage had been through near impenetrable jungle and they had not arrived
on the scene until two days after our own coming.
Nevertheless,
they attacked us,
okay.
They attacked us,
some 100 of them against our force of some 1200 and but for the prisoners we had
an isolated them.
Okay.
Were they brave or fanatical?
What had they hope to gain?
Had their commander really believed that a company of Japanese soldiers could
conquer a battalion of American marines.
Experienced,
confident,
better armed and placed on higher ground.
Okay.
Why do you not turn it around and marched his men home again?
Was it because no Japanese soldier can report failure?
CanNot lose face.
Okay.
I cannot answer.
Are Dead.
We're six men among them,
the stubby and trepid ob who might last scene in Melbourne so drunk,
he could barely stand who's gun pit had been overrun when the Japs overwhelmed a
section of the lines in their first silent rush up the hillside ob who had
helped to drive them out in the counter attack and who had been alternatingly
firing and hurling imprecations at them until one of their bullets took him
squarely in the forehead.
May he rest in peace.
The Japanese dead lay in heaps on the hillside and they filled the trench.
We're obese.
Gun had been located.
Okay,
so that shows the will of the Japanese fighters.
No doubt about it.
They were hardcore and they got told to attack with a hundred guys against 900
or 1200 and they said,
all right,
let's do this
now the
life,
the existence in this jungle was harsh.
Back to the book,
the puffing of my lips and eyes symbolize the mystery and poison of this
terrible island.
Mysterious perhaps,
I mean to say new Britain was evil,
darkly and secretly evil.
A malefactor,
an enemy of humankind,
an adversary really dissolving,
corroding,
poisoning,
chilling,
sucking,
drenching,
coming at a man with its rolling,
Ms. Green Mold and ceaseless downpour,
tripping and in with his numberless roots and vines poisoning him with green
insects and bugs and treasures.
Tree bark turning the son from his bones and cure from his heart.
Desolving him,
the rain,
the mold,
the damp steadily poking each plucking each cell apart like tiny hands tearing
at the petals of a flower.
Desolving him I say into a mindless formless fluid like the sop of mud and to
which is feet forever,
fall in a monotonous slop,
suck,
slop suck.
That is the sound of nothingness.
The song of the jungle we're in.
Everything falls apart in hollow harmony with the rain.
Nothing could stand against it.
A letter home had to be read and reread and memorized for a fell apart your
pocket and less than a week,
a pair of socks,
socks lasted no longer a pack of cigarettes became sodden and worthless unless
smoked that day.
Pocket Knife Blades rusted together.
Watches recorded the period of their own decay.
Rain made garbage of the food.
Pencil swelled and burst apart.
Fountain pens clogged and appoint separated rifle barrels turned blue with mold
and had to be slung upside down
to keep out.
The rain.
Bullets stuck together and the rifle magazines and machine gunners had to go
over their belts daily extracting an oiling and reinserting the bullets to
prevent them from sticking to the cloth loops and everything.
Lay Damp and sodden at squashy to the touch exuding that steady,
musty reek that is the jungles own that individual odor of decay rising from
vegetable life.
So luxuriant growing so swiftly that it seems to hasten the decomposition from
the moment of birth.
It was into this green hell that we were inserted a day or two after the march
and here was fought that battle with the rain forest here,
the jungle and the men were locked in conflict,
far more basic than our shooting war.
The Japanese for here,
the struggle was for existence itself.
The war was forgotten.
Who could comprehend it?
Who cared
and
route.
What do you say?
A and I have not spent that much time in the jungle.
I spent some,
I think as long as I've been in the jungle was maybe a month and it wasn't as
bad as this.
It wasn't raining as that much,
but I can't even imagine just that constant,
there's no escape from it.
There's no escape from it and it's even worse for lucky.
And I'll tell you why.
Back to the book,
I would be wet,
not only from the rain for sometimes it's stopped and at other times it did not
fall so fast that a jungle hammock could not repel it,
but because an affliction which I had begun,
which had begun,
the moment I left Australia was now again active.
Okay.
It had begun during the discomforts of Guadalcanal had disappeared in the
civilized living of Melbourne and had reappeared on good enough island,
New Guinea.
And now on new Britain
I laid,
I learned later from doctors to call it and your recess when asleep,
the bladder empties.
And that is that.
So he puts that really nicely,
but here's what's going on because of the stress that he's under when he goes to
bed,
he pisses in his pants and it's just,
he just,
he can't stop it and there's nothing he can do about it
and it won't go away.
In fact,
it went away.
It will go away when the stress stops,
when he to Melbourne is all good.
It stops,
get back out there and the stress of combat,
the stress of the environment and when he goes to bed,
he pisses himself.
Hmm.
And
certainly he made a decision to put that in this book for a reason.
Yeah.
And the there is there,
it does fall into the story a little bit.
But the reason I love that he put it in there is because it's just another thing
that he's dealing with.
And he's not even ashamed of it.
You said,
yeah,
can't,
I'm stressed out.
I'm scared and I'm pissing myself,
but guess what?
I'm still going on patrol.
Back to the book,
the last patrol was a prolonged one of several days.
We were taken by landing boat down the east coast to a place called old,
not Timo,
and they're deposited.
The place had once been inhabited by the Japs,
but all they're in placements were now empty.
Those are the enemy who were discovered when the last extremities of ordeal.
Some were overtaken crawling on their hands and knees,
some so badly decomposed.
It was as though their feet were rotting off some wing,
perhaps no more than 80 pounds,
some without weapons,
all without food and all possessed of that indomitable fighting spirit.
That was the Japanese imperial armies greatest asset.
The one single factor that made a poorly equipped soldier,
a first rate foe.
They all resisted and they were all destroyed.
Bayonetted for the most part for it was file for,
it was folly to fire on patrol in unfriendly unknown territory.
One of these stragglers was strangled in cold blood by the kid.
A youngster who,
although already a veteran of Guadalcanal was hardly acquainted with a razor,
he would go mad two months later.
So they come up across these Japanese total,
80 pounds
malnourished.
Some of them didn't even have weapons and they're just trying to fight.
Anyways,
he ends up with a hernia.
So lucky well ends up with a hernia.
And the EEG,
he gets pulled off to go take a look at his hernia and they say,
yeah,
you got a bad hernia,
but it's not bad enough.
You're going back to the front.
Then the army comes and replaces them there.
And uh,
next thing,
next
move is they go to train adequate at a place called [inaudible] blue island or
doing another training to get ready for another island campaign.
And here we go.
Back to the book.
The food was bad too,
and the tents were rotten and punctured with holes.
There was no water except what was caught in our helmets during the night.
We bathed by dashing,
naked into the rain,
soaping ourselves madly in a race against the probability of the rain ceasing
and being left streaked and sticky stope soap.
And we washed our clothes by boiling them in cans of rainwater.
Our jungle rot had become so bad,
so persistent that there was an appointed time each afternoon for the men to
take off their shoes and socks and a lie out on their sacks with corrosive feet
thrust out into the sun.
But we had borne all this before and we could bear it again,
nor could mere bad food or leaky tents press upon the ardor of my comrades.
It was the death of hope that bore us down.
They're in always been hope,
hope of relief,
hope of the sun,
hope of victory,
hope of survival.
But when they came and told us that none of us were going home on rotation,
we strangled hope and turned into wooden soldiers.
The future look to innumerable enemy held islands and a numerable assaults.
And we had already noticed how the ranks of the new river originals were
dwindling with every action
or even a few suicides to suggest how despairing some could find the situation.
Then
the thing changed.
They came and said half of the originals could go home so these guys get the
word,
hey look,
we're praying for another assault but half of you originals are going to go
home.
There was joy and then once the method of selection for the state side bound
became known,
there was anger.
There would be a drawing,
a state side lottery in which men's names will be pulled from a hat,
but only the names of those who had never been in trouble.
I was among those whose name did not go into the hat and so was runner and who's
your and chicken and souvenirs and a host of others.
It seemed that the originals of the second battalion first marines had been
neatly divided into good guys and bad guys
among us,
their rage to profane anger.
I know now,
how will convict must feel upon being turned down a job after being turned down
a job after job because of his past.
That was what disqualified our past.
It made no difference that we had been punished.
Yes.
Punished again and again for to become customary to solve all problems of
selection this way by marking brig rats for dirty duty and excluding them from
special benefits.
Nor did it matter that we had good war records.
Okay.
In retrospect,
it's easy to forgive my commanders this,
but then it was hard.
It was too much like being unfairly condemned to death.
The injustice of it overwhelmed me and I burned with a resentment that was
dangerous to carry around.
So what uh,
what did,
what a nightmare.
They say,
look,
we're going to have a little lottery.
Some of you guys are going to get at home.
Everyone's happy.
And they say,
by the way,
if you've been in any trouble,
you're,
you don't get on the list.
And that's a death sentence.
The way he's seen it,
right,
right there.
Soon as a death sentence.
Oh,
we're going to keep it doing this island hopping campaign.
We're going to keep going.
There's all these innumerable islands that need to be taken down.
You're going to be on all of them,
and you've already seen x number of guys that you had killed and you're going to
keep going until you're killed.
And so this was like a death sentence,
you know?
Meanwhile,
the guys who might be able to go,
they're just,
they're right there,
like right next to you.
Yeah,
man.
And those guys probably did a lot of the same crap,
right?
Yeah.
So the back to the book mine,
you're my enuresis was more noticeable than before,
perhaps to the agitation of the moment.
Aggravated it.
I know that the men in my tent had been urging me to report it to sick bay.
I did.
The doctor who knew of my case ordered me to be Nika.
I was leaving in the morning.
So
with that,
he basically says,
okay,
you know what?
I'm pissing on myself.
The guys have been telling me to go see the doctor about it.
I haven't done that.
I have a hernia.
I'm going to go to medical.
So he goes to medical and the doctor says,
okay,
you're going to go to Benito.
Benito is a,
is a island where they just aren't set up to handle wounded
and when he gets to Benito,
it's,
it's kind of shocking
back to the book,
but Nico was a flash pot but was the big town,
but Nika was Broadway.
Benita had women.
It had buildings of steel and wood.
It had roads.
It had thousands of sailors as sleek as cam ponds.
It had movie amphitheaters,
it had electric lights.
It had canteens overflowing with candy and comforts and Benita had beer walking
the augers from the beach to the Navy hospital.
I felt like a hick on his first visit to New York jeeps and trucks and staff
cars swept over the islands.
Roads raising a busy cloud of dust cranes,
croaked and cranked on the beach,
loading and unloading the boats.
NPS patrol,
the stockade of pointed sticks behind which dwelt the women,
the Navy nurses and Red Cross workers.
Everyone was well fed and unworried.
The seat of every pair of pants was filled and happy.
We,
the lean ones who wore our discontent on our faces and carried our nervous
impatience in our hands,
must have been a disturbing presence in that pairing island incubator.
Yet as I walked along,
I was filled with the uneasy suspicion that would,
it would be the image of [inaudible] and not pursue that would be presented to
America as the Pacific war.
They do that pretty good job of this and the Pacific in the series,
not as good as they maybe could have done because they show,
they show the guys coming onto a beach and there's nurses and they're dressed in
like beautiful,
clean white,
and they're literally handing out lemonade and it's such a contradiction to what
they've been living.
So,
so you get that,
but,
but this image is even crazier in my mind of coming onto this island.
You becoming off Pervu who you're living in hell and here these guys are
whatever,
a quick flight away and they've got movie theaters and they've got beer and
they've got women running around.
It's just totally,
totally different.
I've talked about that a bunch of times on here.
Like you could be,
you could be in world war two,
but if you are on the island of [inaudible] wasn't that much of a sacrifice as
it was compared to somebody that was on the island hopping campaign.
Just it's not,
and it's the same thing.
You know,
there's places I was in Iraq where I would say,
God,
this is crazy how nice this is.
They've got a swimming pool,
the bay,
some of the base said swimming pools.
They got a nice gym,
they've got a nice Chow Hall.
Then you'd go out to some,
some outstation in the middle of,
or some forward operating base,
and these dudes would be live in hard,
totally different for different people.
Now lucky gets put basically into a psych ward.
They want to look at him and he's,
he starts having this conversation with a psychologist and I think this is a
very important conversation.
Back to the book,
he began to question me about my experiences in war.
And as I told them to him,
he shook his head from side to side as though to indicate that my whole
division,
not only myself,
ought to be psychoanalyzed.
Then we talked of books for,
he was well read and philosophy.
Suddenly he broke it off and said,
what did you say you were
meaning?
What was he saying?
Like,
what did you say you did in the Marine Corps?
A scout?
I said,
proudly.
I used to be a machine gunner and the doctor says back,
but that's no place for a man of your caliber.
Now,
I was shocked.
The old shibboleth intelligence had not our government been culpable enough in
pampering the high Iq draftees as as though they were too intelligent to fight
for their country.
Could not doctored gentle.
See that I was proud to be a scout.
And before that,
a machine gunner,
intelligence,
keep it up.
America.
Keep telling your youth that mud and danger are fit only for intellectual pigs.
Keep on saying that only the stupid or fit to sacrifice that America must be
defended by the low brow and enjoyed by the high brow.
Keep fonting head over heart and soon the head will arrive at the complete folly
of any kind of fight and meekly surrender the treasure to the first bandit with
enough heart to demand it.
Be careful.
That's,
I think that we do a really good job now in America.
You get kids that are,
you know,
there'll be enlisted kids with bachelor's degrees and master's degrees in the
army and the Marine Corps in the seal teams.
I don't think we have that as much,
but it's definitely something that you need to watch out for.
And I think especially this goes back to judgment,
I posted that on the other day.
I W I met some young marine,
no,
not young marine,
but you know guys,
probably 25 27 years old and he came into the gym and you know,
it's like,
oh,
he was in the Marine Corps Os and all cement,
which doing the marine corps,
he was an awesome machine gunner.
I'm like,
yes,
like yes,
that's awesome.
And,
but to have somebody think,
oh,
you're just a machine gun or you must've,
you,
no,
no.
Being a machine gunner should be a vaunted,
an elevated position in the world.
Bless the machine gunners out there.
Do you want to talk about a person that can get stuff done?
Go Talk to a machine gunner?
Yeah,
they will make some stuff happen.
They're carrying a big pig have gone around,
they're laying down fire under pressure.
Put him off with the,
I'll put the machine gunner up against one of these intellectuals any day the
week bring it,
but the machine that it can be an intellectual.
Absolutely.
That's the point.
That's the point,
right?
Just because someone chooses to do something that's hard doesn't mean that
they're not smart.
In fact,
I'd go so as far as to say they are searching for and,
and discovering and becoming something that takes a level of mind power to do.
Yeah.
Kind of like the week
superficial assumption is that,
oh,
you're going to choose that kind of that hard thing because it's not really
intuitive to just,
I'm going to go for the hardest thing.
It's,
it's intuitive to be like when you get this easy thing to do because it's
easier.
So when someone chooses the hard thing to do that the kind of that assumption is
that you had no other choice.
Oh yeah.
You know?
Yes.
Perfect.
Numb.
And I think that's what,
I had a guy in high school where he was a year older than us and he was like a
smart guy and had all his stuff to get a good family and he went into the army
and I remember some people were like kind of surprised because like,
oh,
you're going to just do the army that you know,
like doctor gentle here.
Well what are you doing that for?
Cause I want to be a machine gunner.
Yeah,
that's why.
Yeah.
Perhaps the machine gunners
now out on this island,
he's there,
he spends like a month and they're sitting down to watch a movie at the theater.
I remember one time we had the awesome CBS that that worked for were in Ramadi
with us and so they're building,
they're building bunkers.
I'm not kidding.
Like what were their priority builds when they were in Ramadi with me on our
little Camp Camp Mark Lee,
the priorities that they were working on were bunkers were security walls on the
river,
getting barbed wire.
Those are the priorities they were working on.
And my lead,
CB,
my CB chief,
he's,
he had to go to our headquarters for a couple of days to get money and get
equipment and whatever.
And when he came back,
he was great dude.
His nickname was biggie and he was big.
And then one of those things,
yeah,
no,
his,
he would,
he would like his warm up sets on bench.
We're three 15 he was big and he's strong,
he's strong.
And he came back and you know,
he says,
Hey sir,
coming back from Felucia.
And I was like,
oh,
everything cool out there.
He goes,
let me tell you something.
I was like,
what's that baby?
He says,
you know what,
they're building out there.
I said,
no,
I have no idea.
I don't care what they're building other because they're building a theater.
I said,
he said,
they're building
a theater.
I said,
you mean a movie theater?
He goes,
yes,
off the aider and,
and he was just beside himself because here we were trying to build bunkers and
security walls and they were building a theater big.
He didn't like that,
but go cvs,
man.
They kept us.
They kept everything rocking and rolling props once your props to the machine
gunners ops to the CBS for sure.
So they were in a theater that had been built out here and the movie began.
There was an interruption over a public address system of voice announced allied
troops of just invaded northern France.
The second front has been opened.
Okay,
cheers.
And shouts rose into the soft night to be followed by a buzz of excitement.
But then the film began and silence was restored.
Okay.
I arose and left the amphitheatre,
my heart throbbing and excitement.
It was difficult to comprehend this excitement.
It was a mix of thrill and pride,
but predominating was the heartbeat of anxiety for suddenly it had been born in
upon me that great events were happening,
that the war was now rushing downhill to victory and here I was clad and pallet
pajamas and robe lounging around.
The hospital yearning came upon me in a rush and I wept hurrying along the dark
road back to the hospital.
I wanted to rejoin my comrades.
Okay,
so he goes into see Dr Gentle goes into his office and basically they work it
out back to the book.
There's not much we can do for this trouble of years.
The hospital commander told me,
there's no carrying it out here.
What you need is a change of climate and the less nerve wracking assignment,
you're shipping me back the state,
sir.
I asked,
he smiled.
Wayne Lee,
ordinarily,
yes,
unfortunately you marines can't go home unless you're carried home.
So we are sending you back to duty with this,
with the suggestion that your commanding officer have the century wake you
during the night.
I laughed and he laughed and doctor gentle laughed
cause they knew that's not something that's feasible.
What they're basically saying is you're going to go back and you're just going
to piss yourself and you're going to fight and that's exactly what he wanted.
He gets back there and now,
okay,
back to the book,
we left Porvoo victors of Guadal canal in new Britain.
We went out to fight again,
marching into the open job landing craft,
driven up on the beach,
never before where we so confident of victory.
Never again what its price be.
So high.
Hello Lou was already a holocaust.
Okay.
The island flat in almost feature list was an alter being prepared for the
ambulation of 17,000 men.
So they're going on to Pella,
Lou,
and here we go right into it.
They're in their landing craft.
The water began to rub it in.
Little geysers in the air became populated with exploding steel.
The enemy was saluting us.
They receiving us with mortar and artillery fire 10,000 Japanese,
a weighted on the island of Pella.
Pellalou 10,000 men is brave and determined and skillful as ever.
A garrison was since the art of warfare began.
Skillful.
Yes,
it was a terrible rain and it did terrible work among us before we reached the
beach.
Okay.
Our Amtrak was among the first assault waves,
yet the beach was already a litter of burning black Indian fib.
Ian Tractors of dead and wounded,
a mortar garden of exploding mortar shells.
Holes had beer scooped in the white sand or had been blasted out by the shells.
The beach was pocked with holes all filled with green clad helmeted marines.
We were pinned down,
we were pinned down,
but not by mortars alone.
Machine gun fire came from an invincible outpost,
which the Japanese had blasted out of a coral jutting into the bay.
We found an opening in it.
And even then we're filling it with all manners of small arms,
fire grenades,
sticks of dynamite,
dynamite hurled by men who had crept up to it or billowing fire from the flame
throwers who had also gained the whole,
but the answering fire continued to rake are deadly picnic ground.
Okay.
And the reason for that is here for the Japanese had possessed Pellalou for two
decades and had blasted into the coral,
a network of mutually supporting caves so that,
so these,
they'd been there for 20 years preparing for this and so they've got this
massive cave network and Aiden to every time they hit one of these locations,
the more guys would just pop up.
Yeah,
and they also,
the Japanese also had tanks on Pellalou back to the book.
Their tank swooped in suddenly upon us.
They came tearing across the airfield,
a dozen or so of them.
It was startling.
They'd come out of nowhere.
And here we're only riflemen and machine gunners to oppose them.
It was a violent outburst of gunfire.
I poked my head above the crater through the lacy branch work of the scrub
trees.
I saw an enemy tanks streaking along with snipers and camouflage hanging onto
the rear.
It was bought a moment's glance,
but at the time my,
I caught sight of a marine from f company,
a running bowlegged to the rear,
his face,
riving shouting tanks,
tanks and officer grabbed him and spun him around and kicked him and propelled
him back to his post in the crater.
We'd prepared for defense like a caravan attacked by Indians.
The enemy tanks whizzed past their little,
their little wheels whirling within the tracks.
Machine guns,
clattered,
Bazookas,
whammed.
Our airplanes came screeching down from heaven and there rose the detonation of
their bombs and the roar of exploding tanks to my right.
I saw a line of our tanks advancing firing as they came seemed to stop each time
their guns stuttered and it was over.
The jap tanks had been destroyed.
I turned to go and as I did,
nearly stepped on someone's hand.
Okay.
Excuse me.
I began to say,
but then I saw that it was an unattached hand or rather a detached one.
A lay there alone,
open palm upwards.
Clean,
capable,
solitary.
Yeah.
I could not tear my eyes from it.
The hand is the artisan of the soul.
It is the second member of the Human Trinity of head and hand and heart.
A man has no faculty,
more human than his hand.
None more beautiful,
nor expressive nor productive
to see this hand flying alone as though contempt,
you're asleep,
cast aside,
no longer a part of man,
no longer has help was to see war in all its wantonness.
It was to see the especially brutal savage three of our own technique of
rending.
Okay,
and it was to see men at their eternal worst turning upon one another,
tearing one another,
clawing at their own innards with the maniacal fury of the pride possessed.
Okay.
Not much.
I can comment on that one.
Back to the book are casualties were extremely heavy.
Before the day was done.
They would total 500 in the first regimen,
something like 20% this on the first day we were advancing again,
our objective with bloody nose ridge.
This was the high ground visible from across the airfield.
It gave the enemy perfect observation,
advancing across the flat table of crushed coral on which there was hardly a
single depression as we were easily excited as clay ducks in a shooting gallery.
Yeah,
but there was no other route and we had to take it.
Grass cutting machine gun swept the airfield
mortars,
mortar shells fell with the comm.
Regularity of automation.
Marines fell.
They crumpled,
they staggered,
they pitched forward,
they sank to their knees,
they fell backwards.
They kept advancing.
The mortars had stopped.
The first F company wave was advancing across the airstrip,
running low with ranks,
scattered breasting,
a withering machine gun fire that had been,
that'd be gun to rake the runway.
They were falling.
It seemed on real.
He seemed a Tablo,
like a scene from a motion picture.
It required an effort of mind to recall that these were flesh and blood marines,
men whom I knew whose lives were linked with mine,
still more was required in facing up to the fact that my turn was next.
And here is the point in battle where one needs the rallying cry here where the
banner must be unfurled or the song song where the name of the cause flung at
the enemy,
like a challenge.
Here is the mounted charge.
The thing is old as warfare itself that either overwhelmed the defense and wins
the battle or is broken and brings on defeat.
How much less forbidding might have been that avenue of death that I was about
to cross had there been some wholly irrational shout like viva emperor or the
Marine Corps forever rather than that educated voice which in the sang froid
that was at all odds with the event said,
well,
it's our turn now.
It's all you're going to get.
That's all you're going to get.
These marines are getting tore apart by machine gun fire by mortar.
They're getting tore apart.
Marines are falling left and right.
They're continuing to advance.
They're continuing to advance and he's watching this group go across this
airfield getting mowed down.
He wants some kind of
motivation in what does he get?
Well,
it's our turn now crazy.
I bade goodbye to the artist.
He looked at me,
sadly from beneath his helmet,
his face made darker and more angular by its shadow.
He cast a rule for Greg.
Glance in the direction of the air,
Air Strip and the still falling men.
Good luck
kid,
he said,
and turned away.
Okay.
I began to run the heat rose and stifling waves.
The bullet whispered at times and other times they were not all audible.
I ran with my head low,
my helmet bumping crazily to obscure my view like waves rising around a small
ship.
In a moment I could not see lieutenant deep chest or filthy Fred.
I was alone and running.
There were men to my left,
still falling.
I ran him through myself down,
caught my breath,
rose again and ran again.
Suddenly I ran into a shell crater full of men and I stopped running.
So the only cover that they have is a shell crater.
And he dives into this shell crater and there's 10 guys or so in there and one
of them he's calling this one guy walkie talkie.
Back to the book.
Walkie talkie sat below me on the crater floor.
He hunched his shoulders toward me and asked me to twirl certain dials.
I did,
but he could not seem to get through the came the screech of a shell.
I braced my back for it even though I knew that the ones you hear are not the
ones to be feared.
Okay,
but how fear the one that gets you the one you do not here.
Another voice was audible.
Now the fifth marines lieutenant who was wounded who was in fact dying as I
learned later,
we're speaking by walkie talkie to his regimental commander.
Yeah,
the gories fifth marines have gone through,
sir.
He was saying and have achieved the objective.
We are now in contact with the first regiment.
Now
there's 10 guys in there and finally one of the captains speaks up.
How many men?
How many men here from the first marines?
He asked,
we raised our hands,
six a.
That ought to be enough.
We better take that block house over there.
That's where all the machine gun fire seems to be coming from.
As soon as this shell fire stops,
we'll move out against it.
Just like that.
The block house had resisted even naval gunfire.
They did taken Bob's point blank and remain standing.
It was obviously covered by amaze,
have pill boxes.
We,
six of us were to take it.
Captain might be stupid,
but no one could say that he was not gallon.
I felt disgusted and resigned myself to an unprofitable def.
I looked at the men from the WHO regarding us with wonder and envied them for
having retain diplomatic relations with the state of sanity.
Their commander was hardly conscious now,
but he had heard
you waved a hand weekly in our direction and grinned as though to say you'll
never make it,
but there's no harm in trying.
And of course to a dying man,
I suppose.
There was no harm.
So do you think they're going to do it?
They're going to do it.
They're gonna charge this block house six guys,
this block houses,
it's just concrete block house.
Basad machine gun fire coming from it.
They're going to charge this thing that took bombs straight up that to direct
hits from bombs.
Crazy.
They,
they make a run for it.
Back to the book.
The shells drove us back to our creator.
Once again,
walkie talkie had difficulty with the apparatus he could receive but not sinned.
Battalion was asking for positions.
You better report back to command.
Post captain said to me,
but come back out.
So lucky wants to go tell command post what's going on.
You can imagine there's just machine gun fire mortars going off everywhere.
He runs back.
He gets back to the major at the command post.
How is it out there?
Lucky the major asked bad sir.
I said adding nothing for my notion of this battle was still confused.
Jumble of men and movement and explosions in which blistering hot when which a
blistering hot air field was somehow involved.
Then I arose and said,
I better get back out.
Okay.
The major nodded and waved.
Good luck.
Okay.
I took from hold on my Tommy Gun and adjust my pack,
secured my map case and circled the pile of shell casings to return to the shell
grader.
It was my last warlike act for the last time I set my face toward the enemy.
Okay.
About a hundred yards out.
A shell exploded in front of me.
I veered to the right.
Another shell exploded in front of me.
I veered more another shell,
another but closer for more,
another closer.
Still,
I halted a horrifying fact became clear.
I inserted myself between the enemy artillery and their target.
They were hunting something,
perhaps the ammunition dump behind me and we're walking there fire in its
direction.
Okay.
There was no cover to go forward,
was to die.
I could only run away from this approaching death hoping to get out of the
target area before it caught me.
I turned and ran.
Okay.
I ran with the heat shimmering in waves of from the coral with the sweat oiling
my joints and the fear drying my mouth with the shells exploding behind me.
Closer ever closer.
The airfield,
the air filled with the angry voices of shrapnel demanding my life.
Yeah.
I ran with an image in my mind of the Japanese gunner.
A top is ridge bringing each burst carefully closer to my flying rear,
chasing me across that baking table in a monster's game of cat and mouse.
Gleeful at each or burst of speed called forth by a closer explosion and then
tiring of sport lifting the gun and dropping one before me.
Yeah.
Uh,
shell landed alongside me perhaps five feet away,
but it did not explode or at least I do not think it did.
One cannot be certain.
It's such time.
There is a different space and time with fear.
Yeah,
but there was a shell at two foot blob of burning red,
which struck the choral with a thunderclap and seem to glance off into the year
and go wailing away into the bay.
With that,
I called upon my remaining strength and also then the Japanese Gunnar hit his
target.
The ammunition dump was hit.
Okay.
The war ended for me.
I had been shattered.
No good.
A dry husk.
Okay.
Modern war had had me a giant lemon.
Squeezer had crushed me.
Dry Concussion,
heat,
thirst,
tension,
all had had their way with me.
I must've stumbled about unable to speak until at last.
I sank my knees beside to meds,
scratching a fox hole in the sand.
They were startled.
Yeah.
As know from afar,
I could hear them discussing me.
Okay.
He can't think.
What do you think's the matter with him?
Search me.
He don't look wounded.
Maybe he got a near Miss.
Hey Fella,
what's wrong with you?
Can't just say something.
What do you think we ought to do with him?
Okay.
They rose and pulled me erect,
got a shoulder,
a piece beneath my armpits and dragged me like a dummy through the sand.
Life's like a life,
like a life size doll in whom the spring had been broken.
They dragged me to the doctor or corpsman laid me on the blanket,
tied a ticket to me.
He thrust a needle into my arm,
which was attached a running hose to a bottle of liquid,
suspended upside down on a frame.
On a wire frame.
Okay.
The pair who had brought me,
crouched beside me.
What's wrong with him,
doc?
One of the mast,
I don't know the corpsman answered.
He's pretty beat up though.
Blast concussion.
I'm sending him back to the hospital ship.
Okay.
One of the pair of look longingly at the Tommy Gun beside me has glance seem to
say you won't need that anymore.
I told him with my eyes to take it and he slung it over his shoulder with
immense satisfaction.
Then they left.
They had their reward.
Okay.
Mortars were falling as they carried me on the beach with about a half a dozen
other casualties.
We laid there and I wondered,
Dolly,
if the JAP gunners were to catch me after all,
okay.
At last,
the landing boat took us a board and rode off for the ship.
I began to feel shame.
The others were badly wounded,
some put out of pain by morphine and here I lay in a corner quietly.
Retching like a frightened kitten intact my face on blemished,
my bones on broken,
the war was ending.
I was ashamed.
My spirit crept away from the eyes staring from the staring eyes.
That fat is fastened upon us as the boat was drawn up out of the water to the
deck,
people in white coats throwing the rail and two of these at the center gaze with
authority into the boat.
Searching for the wounded most in need of aid.
I shrank from that expert stair when suddenly one of them pointed at me and said
him,
get him downstairs right away.
Okay.
They grasped me,
stripping me naked as they did,
and hurried me down a ladder,
laying me on a table and again,
frosting a needle into my arm.
With the liquid flowing into my body came to warm flood of returning self
respect.
The Dole dispiriting shame had disappeared.
The moment that pointing fingers singled me out,
I had been hurt.
I was in need of aid with the healing power of which he had no inkling the
doctor had restored my spirit to me.
So the war ended for me.
Each day for a week,
I ascend the ladder to the deck and gazed in morbid fascination at Pellalou.
A mile or so away.
Yeah.
They were still fighting.
One could hear the sound of the firing
each day.
The news was bad.
We were winning.
Yeah,
but at a fearful price,
and then the battle had been won.
Extermination had come to the Japanese 10,000 on Powell,
Lou and my regimen.
The first was licking its wounds,
wounds on the beach of my battalion or force of some 1500 men,
the remained,
but 28 effectives.
When the command came for the last assault on that honeycomb of caves in pill
boxes,
which the Japanese had carved into bloody nose ridge in men and blood and agony,
the most costly spit of land in the wide Pacific.
When the command came,
they rose from their holes,
like shades from subcultures and advanced.
They could not run,
they could barely walk and they dragged their weapons but obeyed
and they attacked.
They were taken from the line on the brink of collapse.
Rutherford was killed.
He'd been hit by a mortar shell and blown to bits.
White man had been killed
and the artist,
the artist was dead.
A brave man.
May he rest in peace.
Captain dreadnought fell dead of a sniper's bullet.
Yeah.
It had become a holocaust in the fullest sense.
Okay.
Scores of others in the battalion's perished.
There were those that have not been mentioned.
This book,
friends who did not fit the narrative.
Men whose faces I have not forgotten and whose bravery and sacrifice has
deposited of vast spiritual credit for our nation to draw upon.
Yeah.
These two fell wrestling that island rock from the grasp of it's most tenacious
defender.
Okay.
May they rest in peace.
Sacrifice says
not the blood of your brother,
my friend.
Okay.
Your blood.
That is why women weep when their men go off to war.
They do not weep for their victims,
okay?
They weep for them as a victim.
That is why
with the immemorial insight of mankind,
there are gay songs and colorful bands to send them off to fortify their fate.
They're failing hearts
not to quick in their lust for blood.
That is why there are no glorious living,
but only glorious dead
heroes turn trader warrior's age and grow soft,
but a victim is changeless
and sacrifice.
His eternal
sacrifice is he turned on
and I'll close with the book there.
Obviously it's an incredible book,
okay.
About incredible men.
Okay.
And their eternal sacrifice.
And it's so humbling to hear of their sacrifice.
And I say it over and over and over again,
and I will continue to say it,
that we must live lives worthy of their sacrifice.
The 7,100 killed at Guadalcanal,
the 2,336 killed a pell Lou,
then all the soldiers,
sailors,
airmen,
and Marines who as Robert Lucky said later in his life who fought or who
foremost fighting
fell.
And I think it's also important to remember the example of Robert Leckie who by
his own admission was no angel,
no plaster sinked
but who was truly hero
and remember that that people,
all people have good and bad qualities and people make mistakes and they do dumb
things and get those very people are capable of so much.
And yet so often
we judge,
we judge and we judge and we judge and we cast stones.
But,
but who are we to judge
to?
Who are we to judge when a man like Robert?
Lucky,
lucky,
who not only drank to excess and chase girls and pulled a pistol on his superior
officer and who got so nervous,
so scared,
yes,
I'm going to call it scared.
Who got so scared that he would lose control of his bladder every time he went
to sleep.
And yet he overcame that fear with more bravery in his heart than most of us can
even fathom.
So who are we to judge?
We shouldn't judge people.
We should help them.
And there's probably nothing more we can do to live a worthwhile life then to
help people
to help other people,
Andy and helping other people,
I promise
do you will be rewarded and you will be helping yourself too.
Okay.
And one more thing that we see in this book,
once again,
is the strength of human.
Will.
We see
men tested beyond anything we can imagine.
And then when they pass that test one time,
they get given that test again and then again,
and still they overcome,
overcome the pain and the suffering in the fear.
And yet we can't get ourselves out of bed in the morning.
We can move toward a goal we've set for ourselves.
Don't allow that.
Remember
the Tannery River,
remember the airfield at Guadalcanal.
Remember the discipline instilled in every marine at Parris Island?
Hey and remember what you,
you remember what you are capable of.
If you mobilize your will.
Okay.
And if you keep moving,
you keep advancing.
Okay.
Remember what you are capable of.
If you keep attacking and attacking and keep attacking and don't stop.
Okay.
Don't stop moving forward and don't stop attacking and don't succumb
to the suffering and the pain and the fear.
Don't succumb,
but instead
move forward and attack.
Yeah,
and I think that's all I've got for tonight.
So Echo Charles.
Yes,
the wall.
I'm over here.
Do it a little decompression.
Sure.
Maybe you could mobilize your will.
To let people know.
I Dunno how to support this podcast or something.
I do.
I will make the disclaimer.
It doesn't take much will to do this,
but I do see it as a time to decompress a little bit,
Bro.
Seriously,
yeah.
Can you even imagine I can't.
Getting tested over and over again.
You're going through the hardest possible test with dysentery and a hernia with
this Ontario are hernia.
You're pissing yourself.
Your friends are getting killed.
You pass that test through some miracle and they're like,
yeah,
you got another test.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
To prepare you for the test.
We're going to make you suffer more
and then so you get tested again.
That's cool,
but does not,
doesn't matter.
It's not a final exam.
You're going to do it again.
It,
and you know,
again,
I say this all the time,
this is thousands and thousands and thousands of people did this.
It's not,
it's not.
That's what's,
that's what's important to remember.
This isn't,
this is a civilian.
This guy was a civilian.
Yeah.
It sounds like this crazy extreme since this is all the cases.
Yes.
This is a lot of the case.
This is all the cases he talks about.
He says,
look,
courage was common.
There was a rare case where we'd get touched by this fear and it would overtake
guys and wave wave.
We bolster and back up the best we could,
but this isn't an anomaly.
This isn't those story of the singular hero.
Right?
This is the story of thousands and thousands of heroes and this is the story of
what people are capable of.
People are capable of this proven.
Yeah,
and when you think you can't take any more,
guess what you can.
Yeah.
Amazing meal.
Well,
if I got dysentery,
I wouldn't get out of bed straight up.
Don't let alone all this other stuff.
Yeah.
I'm in bed.
Maybe I'd go to the hospital or something like that,
but then my point hospital,
even echo Charles could employ the will in carry on when this tree.
Yeah,
with,
I even say he got malaria too,
by the way.
You know?
I thought it this friend,
he got it to his friend got malaria,
but he got rid of it to God.
That's when they went to look at his hernia and you're like,
hey,
you got to go back to front.
Oh,
but you got malaria.
Suffer through that for whatever it is.
Yeah.
That's four days.
Okay.
Now you can go back to,
okay,
you're good now.
Okay.
Guys are unbelievable.
All right,
well I feel like we should talk about on it then.
That sounds like a great thing to talk about.
I'll let you talk about,
I'm going to sit over here and decompress will.
Okay.
So I'm,
I'm really glad and this kind of goes without saying,
but I'm going to say it.
I'm glad that we kind of got aligned with,
I mean I already took shroom tech before this,
but actually I get technically it was you who really made me take Krill oil.
No,
I didn't make you think.
Yeah,
but you,
let's say you influenced me enough to actually take action as they say.
But anyway.
Um,
so it's like Kinda,
I compare like the post Krill oil and the pre krill oil situation.
So I was,
you know,
I was into lifting weights and stuff and you know how like weights is a good
kind of wheats is cool because you know how strong you are kind of thing.
You know there's the number one.
Yeah,
it's pretty black and white.
There's the number so you can kind of judge like yeah,
that guy strong or I'm stronger,
I'm not strong,
whatever.
Right.
So I considered myself pretty strong in the weight room.
But Kit is one time,
one of my,
one of our friends came into town.
We have,
you know,
we have the weights,
outside and stuff and they're like,
oh yeah,
you got the weights.
And um,
so he gets under there and he,
and he,
you know,
he grabs a weight,
not heavy,
but he grabs him and I'm thinking in my head like I can do way more than that.
But then I was like,
I can but I have to warm up a lot first.
You know,
cause it's a really,
how strong am I,
you know,
really.
Anyway,
the point there is that was pre krill oil.
I'm not saying I could jump underneath my Max,
no warm.
I'm not saying that,
but I'm saying like my actual strength is closer to my no non warmup strength.
No,
that's a good thing.
You ever,
you ever seen those videos where probably not,
but go ahead.
I don't know.
You may have heard,
you know,
the one where they,
they dress up the,
the young professional basketball player or something.
Um,
oh to look like on,
you know,
an old,
an old man.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
So there's this one,
it's like a,
I think he's like a
pro crossfit guy or pro wait little limbic lifter or something.
So he goes to this beach is this old man and he's heard you guys are strong and
stuff like that.
I think you kind of over does it in my opinion with acting,
but whatever.
And everyone's believing like,
oh,
this old man,
you know,
you probably used to be a weightlifter and he,
um,
and he gets under the way and he's just killing it.
He's embarrassed.
He is just showing up all the guys beating him,
you know,
lifting more wasted than them and whatnot.
Um,
so then he kind of like,
does his old man walk away?
That's how I felt
before the Krill oil.
When it's time to live.
Like I can lift a lot,
but like my everyday life,
I'm like kind of stiff,
you know,
like,
oh,
I gotta get up after all,
you know,
that's it.
That's the Krill Krill oil comparison speech.
And where would you recommend people get the Krill oil that you speak of?
So highly anyway on it.
But he and I looked into that strong.
All my prompts lead towards closure.
Yes,
my goal.
No,
but I'm saying like,
you know how that's your goal,
care stories people want to hear about.
But I think when I,
when I saw those videos,
I was like,
that was me before crew or I really thought that like,
well,
that's how it feels,
you know,
kind of fight.
It's a funny video.
It's a funny thought even really.
But that's kind of how it feels.
But don't have that problem anymore.
I don't feel like that anymore.
So
if someone has seen that video and they might be feeling that that way,
maybe I can solve their pain.
I wish I knew that long time ago.
Anyway,
looked into strong boom.
I remember we were talking about it last week or whatever and I was like,
hey,
does it make your bones?
Yeah,
did it when I'm there on it,
very resourceful.
I'm a resourceful person on is a very good resource.
The website and the answer is yes,
it does.
Helps.
Like even like the onset of osteoporosis,
like all this stuff.
It's like that's,
that's what it's like.
Um,
I didn't memorize all the terms but I know the point,
but it's um,
oh yeah,
strontium and I liked the name it after.
Yes.
Cause strontium,
calcium,
all these things make it so when you get older and you know,
degeneration,
you lose that.
Yeah.
I'll eat in your natural deal,
you know,
maybe.
And you get the strong mom boom to him back in your bones.
Easy money.
So you'd take the Krill oil back in.
Your bones are back in your joints.
Will,
your joints are made up of your bones,
tendons,
ligaments.
Does it go into everything?
It goes into your bones,
so you figure the tendon connection to your bone.
That's,
that's the part that's,
yeah,
that can jam you up.
You get right on your bicep.
Yeah.
It happened.
Yeah,
that's what I heard.
Yeah.
I heard it one day.
It ripped off my bone,
my bicep,
wrist off mobile.
Anyway,
if I had some strong on that one,
that one happened,
maybe it would have,
I don't know.
But nonetheless,
that is what strong bone helps.
So guess what?
I did.
Got some.
No worries.
Um,
but yeah,
there's,
there's not just that,
there's all kinds of cool stuff.
Uh,
warrior bars.
That's another,
I have gotten more of those,
uh,
shroom tech for performance and the pro,
here's the thing.
I think sometimes people will kind of mistake the shroom tech when,
you know,
cause it helps your oxygen uptake.
They think that like,
I'm going to,
when I breathe,
it has something to do with your breathing,
you know,
it's not your breathing or your lungs.
It's the,
the amount of oxygen you take up when you breathe,
you know,
so they can go to your muscles,
oxygen.
Anyway.
That's why it helps.
So if you go hard,
like super hard or uh,
grappling long,
what you call them wads,
right.
We're out of the day.
Yeah.
It helps.
Keeps you out of the red.
Um,
but yeah,
go on there for whatever you do.
You know,
they,
even a workout stuff and whatnot.
It's actually kind of a fun website.
You'd be on there for for a while.
Looking at the cool stuff.
That's my opinion and my experience.
Inner subscribe to the pot.
Actually,
you know what?
We'll talk about Amazon first,
so Amazon click through.
This is a good way to support podcasts.
What you do if you don't already
before you do your Amazon shopping,
go to Jocko podcast.com either on the tab on the top left in green on the top
menu
or on the side kind of towards the bottom is a place to click on just support
through either support Jacobite gas or Amazon.
Click through anyway before we do your Amazon shopping,
click through there.
Then do your shopping.
I actually did that the other day and I don't know if you're watching this on
youtube,
but if you are,
this is what I bought.
Totally necessary and also also if you totally miss this book,
I didn't,
I don't know if I made it clear enough.
The book that we read today is called helmet from my pillow by Robert.
Lucky.
You can get that Amazon,
you're going to put an echo.
We'll have it on the website.
And when you click that and you buy it,
boom,
you'll be good to go.
You will support the podcast,
you will support the lucky family in some way because there'll be somehow being
supported.
Right.
Cause their own,
I'm sure this book.
So it's a good way to support this hero,
this hero,
his family and also get the Pacific.
I don't know if we could put that,
I don't know.
But anyways,
like if you could put it on click through unless maybe someone bought the DVDs.
But we'll watch that and,
and you know what,
when you watch it,
like prep yourself mentally and don't watch it while there's other things going
on.
Sit down on a nice situation,
you know logistically with the good TV set and a good speaker,
system,
Thrones.
Yeah.
And then watch the Pacific and you only,
they're like,
maybe you can watch two at a time,
maybe what,
two episodes,
two episodes.
But watch them close together too.
So you kind of maintain the continuity of the situation.
Right.
Because that's good too.
And when you see it,
man,
it's just an incredibly well done thing.
Yeah,
it's awesome.
And then when you have the background of the podcast of the books and you read
the books,
man,
it's really,
really powerful.
You actually get more more into it.
Oh,
for sure.
You know,
the guys know the story for sure.
You're more invested in the characters and you realize that,
that when you see lucky,
lucky in the thing,
you have his whole backstory of his life when you've read the book and it's
awesome,
you know?
Um,
by the way,
on the podcast website,
there's a whole section,
whole page with all the books of all the podcasts.
Make it easy for the book situation.
But yeah.
So yeah,
before you do your Amazon shopping,
click through the click through the Amazon link and then do your shopping.
And yes,
I did buy this item,
which I'm showing.
So if you look on youtube,
you can see it.
It's to add to our little collection on the table.
Yeah,
it's awesome.
So yeah,
speaking of Youtube,
we have a youtube channel.
It's good.
People have been telling me
for real,
people have been telling me,
not just one person,
but they say,
hey,
you should take,
because k on youtube channel we have the podcasts of course,
the video format excerpts,
just like,
you know,
excerpts from the Po sleek and like chairman,
stuff like that.
And then there's like,
well what do you call them?
That what artistic pieces stuff that it puts some time into,
puts them track a soundtrack on Charles Videos.
That's true.
I just called it,
I forget what I called it,
like discipline something.
I Dunno.
So you made three categories or two to got to play it.
So basically people didn't ask me,
hey,
you should separate them and make them into playlists,
which it kind of knew about.
But I'm not deep into the youtube thing where we know that well,
no,
as far as the customization and you know,
all of that,
which,
which I kind of looked into,
this is what I like about this.
As people gave you a suggestion,
which I saw to you,
you looked at it,
you explored it,
and now you executed on it.
Yeah,
totally.
Did kind of things.
Any other good ideas that people have,
they should post him.
And so that way you can improve even more and we can improve it and serve them
better.
Yeah,
I think so.
I think that's it.
And of course someone going to be like,
hey,
you know,
and they'll say an idea,
it might not be all that good,
but if,
or it may not seem like it's all that good,
but if another person says it kind of unrelated,
you know,
not the kind of words some guys or hey do this,
make this or create this and then someone just likes it or puts a light on it or
says yes,
you're asking for multiple,
well not to split hairs,
but I'm not asking for anything.
Oh,
I'm saying that's what you act on.
Yeah.
So if some someone says this suggestion,
maybe the next day,
two days,
three days later,
another person said the same suggestion,
suggestion unrelated and that 10 the,
you know,
the tendency,
I see a tendency coming up and that's when it started taking action.
As soon as,
hey,
what about the 14,000 I told you to make more videos.
Those are,
no,
because I was watching,
I realized it was watching so many,
I can't even remember who it was,
but I was watching chunks of someone speak the other night,
someone that I was,
I don't know who was an and I was so happy that they weren't short clips and I
was like,
this is why we need more short clips.
Yeah,
because it's really convenient to go,
what's this idea here?
Boom.
You see the name of the video you go with.
Here's the idea.
I want to think about that idea.
Boom,
you're good to go.
And Youtube is good like that.
Where if there's a bunch of them,
which I think we're kind of coming up with,
or collections kind of growing now,
I'd say there's a bunch of them.
How well did you execute when people said make,
when people were like episode 40 to make a video from this to this,
how did you do any of that?
Or did you bill everyone off?
No,
no,
no.
Yeah,
that's,
that's mainly what I base it on.
Oh,
okay.
Phil.
But those are,
they're everywhere,
you know?
So some of them don't quite translate.
Some of them,
I just,
I mean,
I don't want to upload like five in one day and the,
I've read some stuff that it's like,
I don't know.
It's not good to do that,
but I don't know.
That's a,
that's a long story.
I bet.
I don't know.
Let's not,
let's not think about what's good to do and what's not good at it.
They're just got to get,
because you were trying to get,
so,
yeah,
you ain't to,
I dig it,
man.
But yeah,
youtube is good like that where if you listen to just the,
um,
like an excerpt or just a clip,
two minutes,
three minutes,
four minutes,
and you're like,
Dang,
I want to,
I want to listen to some more.
They,
not only are they there to listen if you want,
but they'll suggest,
so you'll have a bit of continuity there instead of like,
oh,
I'm locked into this three hour thing.
And right now.
Well that's,
and that's one thing that's a little bit tricky about this is that when I,
when I'm thinking,
when I'm talking,
I'm thinking in the context of this giant two hour thing.
So sometimes it's hard to just snip out something and you lose a little bit in
my opinion.
Yeah.
But potentially you also gain a lot because you can get it quick and you can
share it with the next guy who's more likely or the next person more likely
listen to it because even now,
man,
people will send me,
you know,
whether it be funny videos,
there's this sodium video that you know,
the guy skipping a piece of sodium across the lake or awesome.
Yeah.
You saw that it's been going around.
I don't know if people look for it and then sent it to me or it's been going
around so now more people are sending it to me because the last like two weeks
everyone's been sending it to me and I want to actually do that.
I want to get the sodium metal.
I don't want to throw it into the water at your house.
I do or if we can find it,
I want to do it and to burn and film it and then just see what else I got to
start looking for where to get some sort of metal,
you know?
Um,
but yeah,
that's the,
you know,
these are good things.
These youtube made the play list,
they're on their excerpts.
I'm putting more on there.
Okay.
There it is.
Yep.
I'm subscribed on iTunes or stitcher or Google play and all the podcast
platforms.
Um,
you know,
that's a good way to support because you're essentially just kind of in the game
in general,
you know,
and that's really the thing because like the more people,
they'll hit us up on Twitter or just like kind of knowing and knowing what
you're talking about or submitting questions,
this kind of stuff.
It does make that circle of like,
it's not just Jocko telling us what to do.
It's kind of like we're all in this group,
you know?
Well yeah,
they weren't,
I ended up with like a common it like hanging out with your friends basically.
Yeah.
Like when I go on the road now,
like I was just out with some firefighters in,
in like we're all,
everyone's telling the same jokes,
but they're all,
yeah,
we all get it exactly right now with them because it's like as if they were
here.
Yeah.
And I was actually talking to them about that.
I'm like,
well,
you know,
w when it first happened,
it could be a little bit strange to me.
Right.
Cause you don't remember them sitting right.
Because no one was sitting there actually.
And I was like,
well sometimes it seemed like the podcast was like,
was me an echo sitting in a room alone.
Right.
But then you realize,
no,
there's a lot of people sitting in here with us and they have their own spins.
This is what's funny is people have their own variations on the jokes and on the
inside things and on what we're talking about.
So it's all,
you know,
they've already taken stuff and spun it out somewhere.
Now they're bringing it back to me.
So I'm part of their right.
I get in,
get inside of their games.
So it's pretty funny.
Yeah.
And that's not to mention the questions that,
that you answer.
It's all everyone's question.
Yeah,
for sure.
It's not like you're like here,
let me think of this question that I think people I have no,
you got it from certain people and you know,
you answer them.
They're like hey,
you know it's like a three way street or something better.
Anyway.
So yeah,
when you're,
I'm subscribed,
you're,
you know,
you're kind of in the group.
It's a good way to support.
I'm also,
Jack was a store called Jocko store.
Okay.
Good story.
Isn't it more like the podcast has a store cause I don't actually have a store.
It's the podcast has a story.
Yeah,
I guess technically we always make it sound like I have a store.
Yeah.
Cause it's called Junkie.
We the store.
It's got Jocko podcast starts.
Jocko store.
Go to the store chocolate store.
It's [inaudible] dot com okay.
See what I'm saying?
I'm going to concede to the point.
There it is.
Boom.
I have a story.
That's what I don't like about it and sounds good.
And so when I say it I think sounds cool.
Sure.
It's on there.
If you want to wear a t a t shirts and represent,
got a new design out there,
we'll kind of knew two weeks,
three weeks maybe I'll put it right.
Yeah.
Garden there.
And actually at the moment it's a new tee shirt,
design tee shirt.
Do you think it can be found in other places?
Okay.
Yeah,
right?
Sure.
What do you mean?
I mean all right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
Found in other places.
Yeah man,
it's good.
But hey look like on the get after it moves,
that's where it can be found straight up.
I don't know,
watch a little game here.
Like I wasn't gonna say anything.
It's the get after it mark,
we've got a shirt that says get after it and now and came highly recommended.
Perfect.
Perfect example of people saying we're,
you know,
be what we're saying.
So like,
um,
like matter of fact is yeah.
Where it was to the point where they were like,
hey,
you should,
you should do it and get after it.
Sure.
They weren't saying that anymore.
They were saying,
when are they gonna get after it?
Shirts come out.
When do they come out?
Oh,
I didn't know what we're doing that yet,
but apparently we are so boom,
they're out and they got to with psychological work,
man,
I'm glad they did because I think they turned out good.
It will simple like most things.
Anyway,
these shirts are cool I think,
but go to [inaudible] dot com and look at them.
You think they're cool.
You think you want to wear one represent in the wild.
Go ahead.
Get one support one that way.
Also some,
you know some women's stuff out there.
Women might be underrepresented overall,
but I think that the women that are kind of in the game that listen,
that get after it,
they get after it.
Hard to make up for the numbers,
you know?
See what I'm saying?
Like the quality
greater than the quantity.
Anyway,
I've got some patches on there too.
The rash guards,
of course I'm going to put a new one out.
It's in the works.
It's like rit ready to be pushed out here in a few days.
I think maybe a week.
Um,
so yeah,
if you're into Jujitsu,
that's why I think that's the primary reason I made them.
But they're actually for surfing.
Okay.
Bodyboarding what Jocko calls sponging spot cycling,
crossfit,
any kind of workout where you need,
you know,
like maximum mobility,
but you still want to go with like a shirt on.
Sometimes you just go no shirt.
But yeah,
go no shirt.
You're not supporting the podcast.
Correct.
Uh,
and you know,
the,
we are,
I think,
you know,
we kind of did some calculations.
I think the new rash guard might,
I'm not saying it will,
cause we don't know yet.
They're not here.
They might yield,
was it 24?
Oh,
so echo did,
he's got the sample one,
the old one sample.
And the sample one you said gave you like 27%.
I thought 24 but you know what?
Now that you mentioned it,
I think it was 27 yeah.
Yes.
Up from 19.
Yeah.
Which is a lot,
but that's only one case study.
So that's what I'm saying.
We're really good at delegating blind tandem.
This is actually true.
Where I went and I practice.
I did some rounds.
And you're looking at when you're done rounding,
you're kind of talking with the boy's afterwards.
Yeah.
And girls in,
in our case,
because Haley was there too.
We're talking and I thought we were done.
We were done.
Somebody called me like,
hey guys.
And then David just means bullier.
He's like Ho nephew.
Like actually actual nephew,
like from like his dad's brother or something.
I might get that part wrong,
but it's,
yeah.
Anyway,
that's a side note.
Yeah.
Well he asks,
is anyone still rolling and go sweat stood around the left shroom tech rash
guard and I said,
yeah,
rolling.
Got It.
All with the lead.
Good,
good deal.
Good experience.
But that's a good deep half guard.
Yeah,
his good deeds,
good brown belt.
All the respect by his deep half guard he's got,
because he's,
he's a bigger dude,
but he got to,
the deaf club card is bigger than Jeff Carson.
He left some trimmed up a little bit,
but nonetheless.
Yeah.
Good.
Good training.
Also psychological warfare.
So if you don't know what that is,
it's an album with tracks Jocko talking,
but he's not just talking.
He's talking with the intent of getting you through any moments of weakness that
you might have in your getting after it.
Journey isn't,
it goes beyond might have,
right.
It goes into actual moments of weakness,
not that you aren't in a moment of weakness,
you're looking at actual donuts there in front of you.
They are breaking you down mentally,
boom,
click that,
hit play,
get the track in there.
The actual amount of potential moment of weakness,
there's a moment of weakness is upon us.
We're going to feed it like a logical warfare and we're getting requests now for
the second one.
Yeah,
I'm going to start thinking about that.
What that's going to be like.
Yeah.
And if you want recommendations of what particular moments of weakness or you
might have that need to be overcome and there's a common theme as echo referred
to.
Sure we will.
And if it's gotta be something that I've dealt with before,
right?
Right.
Because I can't just make up some way of overcoming a weakness that I've never
experienced.
Now I've experienced a lot of weaknesses,
but if you come up with something that I've never experienced,
then we're going to have to just forego that one cause I'm not gonna make it up
for,
I'm not going to make up for sobriety.
Might not work.
Right.
It's hard to manufacture.
You know,
you can't manufacture Inspirado as the great tenacious d said.
Yeah.
I think that's a good idea.
I got some,
we'll talk about it comes from a quietude.
That's where it's got to come from.
Sure.
I still get quiet,
dude.
That's a d.
Well,
yeah,
that's a good on psychological warfare,
Jocko Willink,
iTunes,
Amazon music,
all those good.
It's probably any music outlet.
A bunch of music outlets.
Yeah,
just jump on that.
It helps,
man.
I eat and I use it.
I don't recommend this,
but I used it when I was like,
yeah,
I don't feel like working out.
This is a big thing for me because I kind of had it like that where I'll be
like,
oh I'm just going to rest because I don't feel like it.
I didn't get nine hours of sleep socks do it tomorrow.
No.
Yeah man.
So,
and it really worked with that.
The workout one.
A guy.
Yeah.
You said it works 100% of the time.
Yes.
Like to wake up one.
Yeah.
Cause there's all,
you wake up tracks.
A guy on Twitter said a number
awake of tracking didn't work.
It failed.
And then he said,
but I made it to the number two wake up,
which isn't the way they're set.
They're set like you listen to one that's going to get you up if it doesn't
number two's waiting and you've got the number two and then he woke up.
So we're still batting a thousand overall.
Yeah,
the overall campaign.
Right.
But yeah,
the campaign is a wind.
But we did,
we did take a digger from one dude that just didn't get out of bed after
listening to psychological warfare.
Get out of bed track.
The one he had to go to track two but were there,
he had some reserves,
got some backup.
I don't think anyone's made it to three yet.
No one's made it to the wakeup track for you haven't been there yet.
That must make it even to make it the tee.
You must be one tire dude.
Once I had like a hard night before.
You must have a hard workout waiting for your son.
I don't know something but yeah,
my experience,
hundred percent success rate but I,
and then I started doing it just cause just cause I want to get flustered and no
reason.
Yeah.
And it's weird because it's not tropical row row.
We'll get cause you can,
it's not that,
it's,
it's almost like this.
Some people say to me,
Hey,
can you do one of you yelling?
I'm like,
well I don't really yell a lot man.
Like I didn't get,
I'm not a yeller now I,
let me see,
let me rephrase that.
If we're in the gym and like I'm pushing someone like an MMA fighter that's in a
workout,
I'm going to come on,
you know,
I might raise my voice a little bit,
but I'm not going to yell at you.
They Google,
you know,
the drill instructor type thing and it's not,
this is not what I do see.
Maybe like how that could be effective.
But in these cases,
that's not the mood you're in any way.
It could be effective for certain instances.
Yes.
And actually like I've been doing some little videos in the morning.
Oh.
And,
and I realized when I watch him that I'm getting a little bit aggressive with
the way I'm talking and it's not,
it's not like I'm saying,
okay,
I get it.
No,
I'm just starting to talk.
And then I start getting,
naturally,
I start escalating my own situation because I'm starting to think about when
I'm,
when I'm saying it means something to me.
So when I'm saying,
Hey,
you know,
you're wasting your life right now,
I start think of them that way because I know that there's someone that's
actually wasting their life right now.
And so it starts getting a little bit escalated and so maybe on psychological
warfare to there'll be some situation that s that I personally escalate on,
but yeah,
it would be natural,
right kind of thing.
Yeah,
because you can't manufacture Inspirado.
There you go.
But yeah,
it's good.
Like you just kind of explain like kind of the logic behind it,
like see what you're doing right now,
but do you see that in,
well I guess now I do shoot,
then you get up anyway.
Yeah,
I use the one that now,
sometimes I abuse it.
Well,
I don't know.
I'm feeling fired up and just put it in and get more fun.
Get talked into feeling even better.
That's how dangerous state also when you're clicking through Amazon,
you can also get Jocko white tea,
which it may not seem like a big deal and maybe it isn't,
but maybe it is.
I tell Ya,
judging from some of the,
some of the reviews on Amazon,
I'm redoing.
After Drinking Jocko white tea,
I found I was overcome with the insurmountable urge to get after it,
so much so that I was able to defeat all my foes in a short amount of time.
On a side note,
I have found that Jocko white tea is best served over ice and consumed from the
skulls of dead enemies.
Now,
you know,
I don't know what situation this individuals in,
right,
but obviously he's in combat situation.
He's got photos that need to be killed and he's drinking from their skulls and
even in that really stressful environment,
you know,
the t's helping him,
which is cool.
I'm glad that it's helping him doing positive things against the enemies of,
of good in the world.
Also,
good evening echo and Jocko.
I woke up weighing 115 pounds of the day.
The white tea arrives two cups later.
I reward myself when I was now roughly 250 pounds,
so he more than doubled his body weight after two cups of Jocko white tea.
I think my team was a little loaded and obviously gave me more than the 20%
increase in gains that was promised and I don't think we actually promised
anything.
I didn't promise that,
but I think it kind of speaks for itself.
And this is the important,
this is why I wanted to make this one's very important.
Also cruising went up roughly 200% and so there's that as well for everybody,
you know?
And,
and there you go.
Scientific cruising is up 200% which is positive.
Also weigh the warrior kid.
I got the first hard coffee,
I got it in my hands.
They sent me one,
they're sending me more,
but no,
Dang it's three hours right now.
We've been talking for three hours.
That's my fault.
Oh,
that's a long time.
And I was going to read a little excerpt
and I think I'm going to anyways,
it's already been three hours but,
but so
young mark is,
he's going to jump off this bridge.
He's,
he couldn't swim in the beginning of the book.
Now he knows how to swim.
But his goal is to jump off the bridge into the river and he's goes up there to
do it and he's scared.
He gets scared.
He's not going to feed,
just can't jump.
So uncle Jake,
who used to be a seal,
who's now with his young nephew,
tried to show him the warrior way,
goes up on the bridge and he said,
what's going on buddy?
He said,
in a calm voice.
I don't know.
I said,
I'm just,
you're afraid,
aren't you uncle Jake asked,
but he wasn't even asking.
He knew.
He knew I was scared.
There was no point in denying it.
Uncle Jake knew it as plain as day.
Yes.
I finally said into quiet tone,
too embarrassed that I was afraid.
Then to my surprise,
Uncle Jake said,
that's normal.
What?
I responded,
shocked it uncle Jake statement.
I said,
that's normal.
You're doing something you've never done before,
so it's normal to be a little hesitant.
It's called fear.
It's a normal emotion and it's okay.
Then he added,
well,
it's okay,
as long as you can control it.
This made no sense to me.
How am I supposed to control fear and how would you know you're not afraid of
anything?
Uncle Jake sat quietly for a minute.
Then he said,
I wish that were true.
What do you mean?
I asked him.
Well,
you said I'm not afraid of anything and that is just not true.
Fear is normal.
In fact,
fear is good.
Fear is what warns you when things are dangerous.
Fear is what makes you prepare.
Fear keeps us out of a lot of trouble.
So there's nothing wrong with fear,
but fear can also be overwhelming.
It can be unreasonable.
It can cause you to freeze up and make bad decisions.
Core hesitate when you need to act.
So you have to learn to control fear and that's what you need to do right now.
Okay,
that sounds great.
And I would really love to make you happy and overcome my fear.
But I don't know how
uncle Jake thought about that,
about what I had just said for a few seconds.
And then he said,
okay,
well the first part of controlling fear you have already done and that is
preparation.
You've done plenty of preparation to be ready for this moment to face this fear,
starting with dunking your head all the way up to swimming,
all around and back and forth across this river.
You have done little jumps off the river bank.
All of the last several weeks have been preparing you for this,
this jump and all that preparation works to help overcome the fear.
Imagine how scared you would be if you still didn't know how to swim.
You'd be horrified,
but you have prepared.
Then why am I still scared?
I asked Uncle Jake simple.
He said,
because there's still an element of the unknown.
You've never jumped off anything this high before so you don't know what it
feels like.
People are afraid of what they don't know or what they don't understand,
but you have prepared.
You know it is safe.
You know you are ready.
It's just this last little bit of fear that has to be overcome and you know how
you do that.
I have no idea.
I him,
you go,
just go.
I asked uncle Jake now partly thinking he was just joking.
Yes,
you just go.
You see fear lives in the moment,
that powerful moment between when you decide you are going to do something and
when you do it.
Once you go,
once you start,
you won't be afraid anymore.
You overcome fear by going and it is the same in many aspects of life.
Parachuting,
talking in front of a crowd,
taking a task,
running a race,
competing in Jujitsu.
The fear is in the waiting,
so once you have planned,
once you have prepared and trained and studied,
there is only one thing left to do.
Go
and that's it.
Yes,
that's it.
As soon as uncle Jake finished those words,
he stood up,
looked at me,
yelled out,
who y'all?
And jumped off the bridge.
Okay,
just go.
I thought to myself,
I stood up,
stepped up onto the edge of the wall and look down at Uncle Jake who had just
come back to the surface and was looking up at me with a big smile on his face
with all my heart and lungs.
I yelled out who you are and stepped off the bridge past my fear and into the
unknown.
I felt myself falling for a while and didn't wash.
I was in the water.
Okay?
I came to the surface and had a big smile on my face.
I can fly.
I yelled,
So
little excerpt.
Dang those good man on the way of the warrior kid.
It comes out May 2nd.
So go and go.
Order the book for,
for you,
for your kid,
for your neighbor,
for your nephew,
for your niece,
for the school of library,
whoever ordered them.
So the publisher that's making this book,
we want them to know that they need to print a bunch of these,
okay?
They don't know that right now.
They don't know how many kids want to get after it.
You don't know that.
They don't know that and they're not going to print it off.
It's the same thing that happened with Jocko White Tea,
right?
You remember that?
That shortage,
the anger,
the frustration,
the nation wide,
19% drop in performance across the board of you.
Remember that?
Don't let it happen here.
Same thing.
You can order that.
You can also preorder discipline equals freedom.
Field manual comes out October 17th
okay.
that's the book.
Yeah,
that you asked for.
So you can order that one too.
And of course extreme ownership.
You can get that one.
People buy it and then they buy it for their team and it spreads.
So pick that up for you and your team up and down the of command extreme
ownership.
Beyond that,
if you want some direct action and interaction with your company that you work
out,
you can contact our company echelon front me,
Leif Babin,
JP Denelle,
Dave Burke.
We can get in the game with you.
info@echelonfront.com.
Lastly,
if you don't know,
we have mustard zero zero two coming up at the Marriott Grand Marquis in New
York City,
May 4th and fifth leadership strategy tactics.
Again,
me,
Lafe,
JP,
Dave Burke,
and of course
probably most important Echo Charles.
He's going to be there.
Yeah,
and he might try and hide,
but he can't because none of us can cause there's no green room,
there's no backstage,
there's just all of us together getting after it.
It,
of course before the muster you can find us.
We're cruising kind of hard on the interwebs,
on Twitter,
on Instagram,
and he ended up facey book
echo is that Echo Charles and I am at jockowillink
and finally,
thanks to all the service men and women out there who
in this uncertain world,
and it's certainly is an uncertain world today filled with evil.
All of you that walk away from the comforts of home and into the unknown
to face or enemies.
Okay,
thank you.
Then to the firefighters,
police and law enforcement.
EMT is in the force,
first responders here at home.
Thank you for what you do day in and day out.
Putting yourself at risk for us.
Yeah.
And to everyone else out there facing what you're facing,
challenges at work and challenges with family and challenges with yourself and
challenges in your head and challenges with life.
Okay.
Remember what you as a human being are capable of.
Remember what your will
is capable of
and then keep moving forward.
Keep attacking.
It keeps getting after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.